GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
WAITING FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS
TO COME WE HAVE A FULL.
REALLY FULL AGENDA SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
THE FOLLOWING.
ITEMS ARE OFF CALENDAR SO FEW
HERE FOR THESE.
THESE ITEMS THEY WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY. OF ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. NINETEEN ELEVEN LACKEY
PULLED BY COMMITTEE.
I'M ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
TEN CHAO PULL BY COMMITTEE.
ITEM AB TWENTY FOURTEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA PULL BY AUTHOR.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTEEN POLL BY AUTHOR.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. PULL BY AUTHOR.
SO WE WILL BEGIN AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND SENSE.
MR LOW IS HERE AND SIGNED UP
FIRST WE WILL BEGIN WITH HIM.
ONE OF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
.
FIRST LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMMITTEES EFFORTS AND
WORK ON THIS.
I MEMBERS GUN VIOLENCE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY LEADING TO OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DEATHS EACH YEAR.
AND APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND A SUICIDES RELATED TO
FAR ARMS.
EVERY YEAR.
HAS APPROXIMATELY OF A FEW
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
EACH YEAR IT'S IMMORAL HOW MANY
INNOCENT LIVES WE'VE LOST TO
FIRE ON VIOLENCE.
AND THIS BILL RESTRICTS FAR I'M
POSSESSIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS AT
RISK OF HARMING THEMSELVES OR
OTHERS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WOULD.
PERMANENTLY REMOVE FIREARMS FROM
ANYONE PLACE PLATE THEN PLACED
ON TWO FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS.
WITHIN ONE YEAR.
THE INDIVIDUAL COULD STILL
PETITION TO HAVE A FIRE ARMS
RETURN BUT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COMPLETE THE FORMS. THEMSELVES
AND AUTHORIZE RELEASE OF THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS.
TO THE APPROPRIATE COURT FOR
REVIEW OF THEIR CASE ONE BE VERY
CLEAR THAT.
THE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT
MADE IN THIS COMMITTEE WILL ALSO
OPPOSED TO RIGHTS PROCESS. AND
SURE THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN
PETITION EVERY FIVE YEARS.
WITH ME TODAY IS JOHN HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND DOCTOR JORGE WONG BEHALF
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION.
GREAT THANK YOU AND AND BECAUSE
WE HAVE SO MANY ITEMS ARE.
LIMITED TO MINISTER TO MINUTES
AND I'M GOING TO BE REALLY
STRICT ABOUT THAT TODAY.
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. SHAWN HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT
WERE IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE
ON FIREARM ISSUES WE TEND TO
STAY OUT OF THOSE BUT.
A VERY DIRECT IMPACT ON
PROSECUTORS WHEN SOMEONE IS.
SUBJECT TO A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLD AND DISCHARGED FROM A
FACILITY. SUBJECT TO A FIVE YEAR
PROHIBITION ON.
THE PURCHASE POSSESSION OF
FIREARMS.
THEY CAN PETITION WHEN THEY
FILED A PETITION TO GET THOSE
WEAPONS BACK PETITION COMES TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
REVIEW THAT PETITION AND DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO CHALLENGE IN
THE GROUNDS FOR THE CHALLENGE
WOULD BE THAT WE BELIEVE WE CAN
PROVE BY A PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE.
THAT THAT PERSON IS LIKELY NOT
TO USE FIREARMS SAFELY IN THE
FUTURE.
I IT'S A BURDEN THAT IS HONEST
APPROVED IF WE DON'T MEET THAT
BURDEN THE PERSON RACKETS THEIR
FIREARMS BACK. THAT'S NOT THE
BURDEN IN MANY OTHER STATES MANY
OTHER STATES PUT THE BURDEN ON
THE PETITIONER. IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S ON US AND SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING TO DO WITH AB NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT IS TO. MAKE SOME
CHANGES THAT PROCESS THAT GIVE
US
TIME AND INFORMATION TO MAKE A
KNOWLEDGEABLE AN APPROPRIATE
DECISION WHEN WE'RE DECIDING HOW
TO HANDLE THAT PETITION.
EXTENDING THAT PERIOD OUT FROM
THIRTY DAYS TO SIXTY DAYS FOR
RESPONDING TO THE PETITION.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS. BY WAY
OF THOSE WOULD COME INTO THE
COURT THE COURT TO DETERMINE
WHAT'S RELEVANT WE WOULD THEN
GET TO SEE THOSE RECORDS.
I AND THEN AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED WHEN SOMEONE
SUBJECT TO TWO FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLDS WITHIN ONE YEAR. GOING
FROM A FIVE YEAR PROBATION TO
LIFETIME PROBATION. BUT BUILDING
IN SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO COME BACK BEFORE THE COURT.
PETITION EVERY FIVE YEARS TO
POTENTIALLY GET THOSE WEAPONS
BACK.
.
UNDER THE PROCESS THAT THAT
EXIST TODAY.
STRUCTURALLY HOW THAT THAT
PROCESS PLAYS OUT US WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A VERY COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO AN ISSUE THAT BUT
CERTAINLY IS.
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO FAMILIAR
IN OUR SOCIETY. I'D ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BOB DYLAN IS CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SHARE MY. EXPERIENCE WITH
YOU SOMEBODY STUCK TO HER WHO
ALSO PAST PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION. A FEW YEARS BACK
AROUND TWO THOUSAND FIVE WAS
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH A TWENTY
THREE YEAR OLD. A FILIPINO WOMAN
WHO WAS ACTUALLY.
GOING TO THE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION PROCESS AS A
RESULT OF CHILD ENDANGERMENT SHE
WAS ACTUALLY FIFTY ONE FIFTY
TWICE WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS. US
YOU HAVE A BRIEF HISTORY WITH
METHAMPHETAMINE AND JUST REPLACE
THE CHAU IN DANGERS THAN THEY
DID A SITUATION OF WHICH POINT A
FAMILY REQUESTED FOR HER TO BE.
INVOLUNTARILY HOSPITALIZED FOR
EVALUATION.
SHOULD ACTUALLY HAVING SOME
PSYCHOTIC EPISODES AND ALSO SOME
DISSOCIATIVE. EPISODES ALSO ARE
GOING TO FOLLOW REUNIFICATION
PROCESS PART OF THE ORDERS WAS
FOR HER TO BE IN THERAPY. AND
AFTER THAT SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS PROCESS I CAME TO. A
CONCLUSION TO THE LAST OF COURT
HEARING WHERE SHE ALSO REALIZED
THAT SHE WOULD ACTUALLY NOT BE
ABLE TO REGAIN CUSTODY OF HER
CHILD CARE FOR YOUR CHILD
BECAUSE. SHE WAS SOMEWHAT
INCONSISTENT WITH MEDICATION
TREATMENT AS WELL AS THERAPY AND
IN THE.
PROFESSIONAL CAME A FINAL LIKES
AND SHE WAS
QUITE THE STRUCT.
I MEAN THOSE HAVING PREPARED AND
SUPPORTED FOR MANY MONTHS TO.
COME TO THIS A PARTICULAR POINT.
THREE DAYS LEADERS OF THE
HEARING OUT SHE WAS ACTUALLY
FOUND DEAD AS A RESULT OF A SELF
INFLICTED GUNSHOT WOUND.
WHEN A PHOTO WITH A FAMILY
AFTERWARDS THAT IT WAS REPORTED
TO ME THAT* CAN ACCESS TO A
FIREARM. AND THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
SHE ACTUALLY GOT IT HOW BUT
THERE WAS A ABOUT THREE DAYS
AFTER HER.
COURT HEARING ON A TWO STATE
SHE WAS FUN ON A FRIDAY. AYE
INSTINCT TERM HUNG ON THE FRIDAY
NIGHT HER MOM TOLD ME THAT SHE
SEEMED TO BE GETTING READY TO GO
OUT WITH FRIENDS AND SHE WERE
CHAIR FOR THE TIME SHE LEFT THE
HOUSE.
SHE DID NOT RETURN IN THE EARLY
MORNING HOURS. OF THE NIGHT
FOLLOWING AND I AM BASICALLY THE
PARENTS FILE A MISSING PERSONS
REPORT COULD YOU.
MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF.
THANK YOU OPTIONS ACTUALLY FOUND
DEAD LIKE THIRTY MINUTES WALKWAY
ANY OTHER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S A SHOT MUCH ROB YOU HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TOM A PSYCHO SHASTA
COUNTY SHERIFF REDDING
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IS NEEDED
IF YOU HELP ME KEEP NAME AN
ORGANIZATION THAT I'M SORRY ME
TO CUT IT OFF BUT WE IT REALLY
TIGHT TODAY.
MICHAEL PIMENTEL ON BEHALF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KOBE WAS EITHER WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SO WHAT WE'RE NOT DYSKINESIA
BERMAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY HERE
KALLIO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SO WHAT I'M GONNA
QUICKLY DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MAGNET THAT EITHER WAY. ARE ON
THE CAN SUPPOSE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX.
PATTERSON.
BY NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FIVE MAYES.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX RUBIO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE OBERNOLTE. I NUMBER
TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY OH ONE
SOLACE AND ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE TWELVE
GRAYSON.
DRIVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
JONES SAWYER.
I JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
SECONDLY DOT DID YOU MAY BEGIN.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KIRK CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
A.
OUR MAJOR CONCERN WITH THIS BILL
IS THE VAST SUITE OF.
THE SCOPE OF THE LIMITATIONS
THAT IT POSES OVER AND EXPENSE
EXTENSIVE PERIOD OF TIME FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
TO BE PRECLUDED FROM OWNING A
FIREARM POSSESSING A FIREARM
AFTER A PERIOD OF A COMMITMENT
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND WE THINK THAT GOES
A LONG WAY. TO.
A NUMBER OF OUR CONCERNS OUR
LARGEST CONCERN CONTINUES TO BE
THAT THERE IS OFTEN A STEREO
TYPE DEBTS ARE DRAWN BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUFFER FROM
MENTAL ILLNESSES AND. VIOLENCE
AND PARTICULARLY WITH GUN
VIOLENCE AND WE WOULD ASSERT
THAT THIS BILL CONTINUES TO
PERPETUATE THAT.
BIAS AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY FOR THE ISSUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE IT'S TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT.
SEATS OVER INTO OTHER AREAS
SUCH AS EMPLOYMENT SUCH AS
HOUSING SUCH AS OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS. AND SO WE WOULD.
OPPOSE THE BILL FOR.
FOR THAT REASON BUT DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED
THANK YOU AND.
GOOD MORNING LISTA BEACON WHAT
THEY SELL YOU A CALIFORNIA
PERSONALLY WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AS WELL AND ALSO
APPRECIATE THE A MAN'S AND THAT
THAT OFFER THAT HAS TAKEN AND WE
THINK THAT THIS IS DEFINITELY A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. ON
BUT WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED AND OUT
OF THE CLEAR THAT THEY SO YOU
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT OPPOSE GUN
CONTROL MEASURES THAT SUPPORT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PROTECT PUBLIC
WELFARE. I'M WE ARE SUPPORTED OR
WE DO WE DO NOT OPPOSE UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS PERMITS I'M
WAITING PERIODS.
OR THE AUTHORIZATION PROTECTIVE
ORDERS TO REMOVE GUNS FROM
PEOPLE WHO POSE A RISK FROM THIS
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS.
PROVIDED THEIR NON
DISCRIMINATORY CRITERIA FOR GOOD
FOR FINDING A PERSON AS.
AS A DANGER.
I UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL.
REQUIRES A LIFETIME BAN ONLY ON
PEOPLE WITH A HISTORY OF MENTAL
ILLNESS AND AS.
MR CHILD HAS SAID IT
STIGMATIZES PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS IT PERPETUATES THIS
HARMFUL AND FALSE STEREOTYPE
THAT SUCH PEOPLE ARE INHERENTLY
VIOLENT AND DANGEROUS.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
VIOLENT CRIMES I DO NOT HAVE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SO NOT ONLY.
IS THIS BILL UNFAIRLY
STIGMATIZING BUT ALSO AND WOULD
BE INEFFECTIVE AT ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING VIOLENT CRIME.
.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE OF MAN'S BUT WE
THINK.
ANOTHER STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AT A BETTER APPROACH WOULD BE
TO ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO
INITIATE AN ACTION TO EXTEND THE
BAN.
SAID THAT WITH THE BURDEN WOULD
FALL ON THE GOVERNMENT RATHER
THAN.
THAT PRESUMING THAT A PERSON IS
FOREVER UNFIT JUST BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A HISTORY OF THE OVEN
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
.
SO AGAIN THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THIS WOULD PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND AND SO WE WE DO
REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR LOW YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT.
IF YOU.
THEIR MOTION.
THEIR SECOND.
OKAY OF SLOTH LE.
THANK YOU FOR FOR TAKING
AMENDMENT.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE IN CONSIDERATION WHAT THE
OPPOSITION.
HAS SAID NIGHT.
AND IF THERE IS ANYTHING ELSE AS
WE HOPEFULLY GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE. WE MOVE FORWARD IF
THERE'S ANY LANGUAGE THAT COULD
HELP PROTECT.
.
MR LOWERED BEEN VERY VERY
COOPERATIVE ON THIS MATTER AND I
AM SURE HE'S WILLING.
ON TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
BUT WE.
AS WE'VE SEEN WE DO NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH
SOME OF PROTECTIONS.
SPECIAL WITH PEOPLE
ON THAT HAVE SOME CHALLENGES
THAT.
.
COULD BE.
SAY DEFINITE AND BE GOOD COULD
BE A DANGER TO THE PUBLIC SO WE
GOT TO CHAIRED RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE.
CULTURAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON
A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
I GOTTA YA. GOTTA YOUR ICON
SALAS FLETCHER.
KILEY KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR TESTIFIED.
YOU KNOW GRAYSON SO.
NO.
ALL.
OKAY.
HE PROBABLY DID KNOW HE WAS ON
CONSENT.
IN THIS RUBIO I THINK WAS ON.
THAT'S TO THE.
SHE'S WORKED.
WHICH THE HARPER IN MISTER FONG.
SO YOUR NEXT MUSTAFA.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AT ONE TIME.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN THIRTY ONE A BILL
THAT EXTENDS THE LIFE OF A
CONCEALED CARRY WEAPON PERMIT
CZW FROM TWO YEARS TO FIVE
YEARS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. AND IS SUPPORTED BY
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN PRIDEAUX
COUNTY SHERIFF'S. THE PAST TWO
YEARS REQUEST FOR NEW CCW SET
INCREASE IN MANY COUNTIES
THE INCREASE IN YOU REQUEST A
RENEWAL IS COMBINED WITH A
RIGOROUS SCREENING PROCESS AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR MANY
AGENCIES.
THE TIMING OF THIS PROCESS POSES
A HUGE BURDEN ON AGENCIES WITH
LIMITED STAFF RESOURCES. AT THIS
BILL IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT
MEASURE DESIGNED TO FOCUS ON
EFFICIENCIES THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR BETTER INVESTIGATION OF
APPLICANTS WHAT WHAT
EXPEDITIOUSLY GRANTING PERMITS
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO PROFICIENT
HOMELESS HE W..
WITH ME TO TESTIFY SUPPORT
ISSUES IN WHICH THERE A. A
LEGITIMATE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE AND SHERIFF THOMAS ECHO
FROM SHASTA COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
MAY BEGIN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
ROBBIE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
FOR AUTHORING THIS SPELL ON AS
HE MENTIONED AND THEY ARE THERE
ARE SOME.
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
CURRENTLY AND MANY OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OUR WHICH
PROHIBIT.
AT THAT ISSUANCE OF THAT CCW IN
A TIMELY MANNER TO THOSE WHO
REQUEST IT. AYE WITH ME I HAVE
AYE SHERIFF TOM THE CINCO FROM
SHASTA COUNTY WHO'S HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE AND HAS AT
LEAST TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BETH MORNING. CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
PROVIDES ISSUING AUTHORITY WHICH
ARE PRIMARILY CHIEFS OF POLICE
AND SHERIFFS TO EXTEND THE
DURATION OF THE CONCEALED CARRY
FIREARMS LICENSE FOR UP TO FIVE
YEARS. FROM THE CURRENT TWO
YEARS.
REGARDLESS OF THE DURATION
ISSUING AUTHORITIES CLOSELY
MONITOR. LICENSEES EL FOUR
INCIDENTS.
VIOLATIONS OR ARRESTS.
DOJ ALSO MONITORS IS TO NOTIFY
SEE SWING AGENCIES OF ARRESTS.
AS WELL AS OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THEY COME IN CONTACT
WITH THE CCW HOLDERS. THEY CAN
NOTIFY NOTIFY THE ISSUING AGENCY
PRIDE REQUEST ACTION AND THE
CASE BE REVIEWED.
CCW APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES ARE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS. OF WHO
MUST SHOW GOOD CAUSE AND BE OF
GOOD MORAL CHARACTER TO OBTAIN.
AND HOLD A CCW LICENSE ALL ARE
WELL VETTED AND BACKGROUND ID BY
THE ISSUING AUTHORITY. AND BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THERE'S BEEN IN MY COUNTY NO
PROBLEMS
WITH CCW HOLDERS COMMITTING A
CRIME OF VIOLENCE.
USING A GUN.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY ONE PROVIDES
BENEFITS FOR OUR CITIZENS AND
THE AGENCIES BY REDUCING.
OVERALL COSTS AND INCREASING
EFFICIENCY FOR THE AGENCIES AS
WELL ENCOURAGE YOU TO PASS A BE
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEN FOR BRINGING THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AS A SHARE STATED.
BICU.
THANK YOU.
AT THE COFFEE SHOPS WHERE.
BE FAIR CHAIRMAN MEMBER SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS IN
RESPONSE TO THE STATE OUGHT.
NAMING ON HIS NATION WERE REAL
TIGHT RIGHT NOW.
OKAY.
MANY HAD CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROY GRIFFITH ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
.
A GOOD MORNING AMANDA WILCOX
WITH THE.
TWENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS
OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE.
I AM I WILL BE BRIEF.
.
THE OF THE DECISION TO CARRY A
LOADED.
HIDDEN GUN IN PUBLIC IS A VERY
BIG RESPONSIBILITY THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY CAN PUT THE GUN
CARRYING INDIVIDUAL AND THE
PUBLIC AT RISK.
AND I THINK THE VERY LEAST WE
CAN DO IN THAT SITUATION IS TO
HAVE A REVIEW EVERY TWO YEARS TO
MAKE SURE THAT COULD COST
CONTINUES TO EXIST BECAUSE THAT
SITUATION MAY CHANGE. AND THAT
THE PERSON IS CONTINUES TO BE OF
GOOD MORAL CHARACTER TO ME
THAT'S THE LEAST WE CAN DO. I'VE
HEARD THIS COMMITTEE SAY MANY
TIMES THAT THE FACT THAT AS THE
OPPOSITION HEARD MY OPPOSITION.
ALWAYS SAYS IS THAT.
THE SEAS.
ARM THERE ARE OUR CCW LAWS ARE
WORKING IN OUR STATE THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN A BIG PROBLEM AND
THE EXISTING LAW IS THAT THERE
IS THE REVIEW EVERY TWO YEARS.
CYBER SUGGESTS THAT WE CONTINUE
WHAT IS WORKING I WILL NOTE THAT
IN OTHER STATES THERE'S A LONG
LIST OF CRIMES IN MISTY'S THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE BY CCW HOLDERS.
THERE ARE SOME IN OP FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THAT WHERE THEY WERE LATER
REVOKED THAT'S TRUE THEY WERE
TRACKED BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT I THINK THIS IS A VERY LEASE
A PRECAUTION THAT WE HAVE THE
REVIEW. OF THE THE INTERMEDIATE
COURSE OF TRAINING AT LEAST
EVERY TWO YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN IN OUR OWN IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HERE. THE
DIFFICULTY OF.
HANDLING A FIREARM IN A VERY
STRESSFUL SITUATION. AYE TO AIM
PROBABLY NOT HIT. BYSTANDERS
AND.
.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THERE
CAN'T BE TOO MUCH TRAINING FOR
THIS.
FOR THAT RESPONSIBILITY LAS I
URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ARE INDIA WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
REBECCA GONZALEZ VOLUNTEER WITH
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU BUT
ANY WITNESSES.
ARNIE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE KILEY. I SELL EITHER SOME
SORT OF STATE AUDIT ON THIS
TOPIC IS THE AUTHOR ANY THE
WITNESSES.
NOTE THAT SHOWED.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY ESTHER I
WASN'T AUDIT THAT WAS DONE.
BUT IN LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE ON THREE COUNTIES.
AND THAT WAS DONE A LAST YEAR
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTION ON
THE AUDIT ITSELF.
WELL I HEARD THAT THIS IS IN
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT SO IS
THERE ANY.
.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS.
BUT NO THIS IS NOT A RESPONSE
TO THE AUDIT THAT WAS THAT THAT
WAS DONE NOW.
I WILL SAY THE AUDIT CONCLUDED
THAT THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS
BACKLOG IN AND OF COURSE IF THAT
IF WE WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE
DIRECTORS PROCESS BUT EXTEND THE
LIFE OF A CCW BUT THE TO TO LIVE
LAW ABIDING.
ME A PERSON.
THAT THIS WOULD ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE IN SOME WAY.
THANK YOU. AND YOUR QUESTION.
IT.
YOU YOU MAY HELP ARE STRICTLY
ESCRIBO.
GREG UP MISTER FONG WE HAD.
BRUCE.
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND I'VE HAD
A.
A QUICK DISCUSSION WITHOUT.
SOME SUPPORTERS NO HALL THERE.
SOME THE NRA AND.
INDIVIDUALS AND I WANTED TO
CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION I'VE
HELPED.
THAT WE WOULD HAVE HOST BONUS SO
WE COULD TALK TO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES.
AND SO I'M GONNA RECOMMEND. THAT
WE VOTE NO ON THIS.
BOB I WILL GRANT RECONSIDERATION
NAKED WE SHOULD.
BECAUSE WE SHOULD CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND WHAT I PROPOSE
TO YOU. WAS.
SENSE LAW ENFORCEMENT NEEDS
RESOURCES
TO GO AHEAD AND CHECK TO SEE CW
SWITCH TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING A
RESOURCE TO SO YOU CAN. GET RID
OF THAT BACKLOG
SOME WE WE DID WOULD.
WITH DNA AND WITH DNA KITS
WOULDN'T EXTEND TIME TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT EJECTED DNA KITS WE
PROVIDE FUNDING SO WE COULD
CLOSE THAT GAP SO WE CAN GET IT
DONE.
AND SO I I THINK THAT IS.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
LOOK INTO FOUND WE HAVE MEMBERS
APPROPRIATIONS AND. NO DEFINITE
TALK TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ABOUT GETTING A NUMBER FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES AT THE KNEES AGAIN
TAKE CARE THE BACKLOG. I THINK
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS A
STATE TO PROVIDE THAT FUNDING SO
THAT WE CAN ELIMINATE DEBT THAT
LOW AND SO THAT WE CAN CAN KEEP.
TO SEE CW ARM POLICIES
PROCEDURES THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.
.
WHAT A SAVING BROKE DON'T FIX
IT?
WE SHOULD KEEP IT AS IS INSULT
THAT I'M RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
BUT AB NINETEEN THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER.
NO JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KALLIO.
CARILLO NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
BUILT ON CALL THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE HAVE.
MISS RUBIO.
I THINK AYE SONGS. XCF.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OH ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN TO
ONE A BILL RELATING TO TIME I
RECOVERY CENTERS AND SCHOOLS.
.
MEDICAL RESEARCH ESTABLISHES
THAT THOMAS CREATING NEGATIVE
NEUROBIOLOGICAL RESPONSE IN A
YOUNG PERSON'S DEVELOPING BRAIN
YOUNG TRAUMA.
VICTIMS SUFFERED REDUCE ABILITY
TO FOCUS ORGANIZE AND PROCESS
INFORMATION LEADING TO LOWER
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT DECREASED
READING ABILITY AND INCREASE
SCHOOL ABSENCES.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO ARE LOW
INCOME MINORITY AND IMMIGRANT.
YOUTH ARE DISAPPEAR
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE LIKELY
THAN OTHERS TO BE EXPOSED TO
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE ANOTHER
DRAMATIC DRAMATIC EVENTS OR TWO
MEDICS CIRCUMSTANCES MOREOVER
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN HIGH
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY. CONCENTRATED IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT FAIL TO MEET
THE EDUCATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF TRAUMA IMPACTED
STUDENTS.
THAT'S EXACTLY IT XR BEER I CAN
PRONOUNCE MY OWN WORDS.
.
IT INCREASES THE EFFECTS OF
TRAUMA AND UP TO BRIDGE.
AND.
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF THESE
KIDS TO.
TO LEARN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NO ONE WILL
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES ON THE
CAMPUS SAYS. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE UPON APPROPRIATION AND
THAT'S THE KEY UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
TO ADMINISTRATE PROGRAM THAT
WOULD A WORRIED GRANTS SCHOOL
BASED CHARMER RECOVERY CENTERS.
BIT BY INCENTIVIZING AND
CREATING THE SENATORS IT IS MY
HOPE THAT MORE STUDENTS WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO VALUABLE EVIDENCE
BASED.
RESOURCES WHICH WILL INCREASE
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS AND IMPROVE
THE OVERALL SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ANDREA
PERRY POLICY ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. THE SPONSORS OF THE
LEGISLATION WE ALSO HAVE MARTHA
MERCHANT ON BEHALF OF CARDS SAN
FRANCISCO AND JAMES ANDERSON ARC
CO FOUNDER AND SOCIAL. IMPACT
DIRECTOR AT THE YERBA MATE
COMPANY.
THANK YOU.
SO YOU HAVE
FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THREE
PEOPLE.
SO OKAY TIME.
HI GOOD MORNING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANDREA CARRYING ON THE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR.
WELL IS THAT CHAIR IN YOUR
STAFF.
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
MEASURE CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE AIMS TO PROMOTE THAT
EFFECTIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STRATEGIES. TO STOP THE CRIME
AND CONSEQUENTLY BUILD HEALTH
THAT HEALTHY AND THRIVING
COMMUNITIES TODAY.
A. B. TWENTY SEVEN A ONE IS THE
BILL THAT WE ARE BRINGING BEFORE
YOU AND EVEN THOUGH WE ARE CRIME
REFORM ORGANIZATION WE ARE ALSO
FOCUSING ON LIFTING THE VOICES
OF CHILDREN WHO EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA. I WILL GIVE THE REST OF
MY TIME TO MY WITNESSES.
HER MY NAME IS JAMES ANDERSON
I'LL BE QUICK GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF HIS BILL I'M
ALSO HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF.
OF THE KIDS THAT COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY. AND I WANT TO SPEAK
IT WITH SPECIFICITY VISIT THE
THAT THE KIDS I'M SPEAKING ABOUT
OR THE KIDS AND NEVER HAD A
CHANCE.
EITHER BECAUSE SOCIETY TOLD HIM
SO OR EITHER BECAUSE THEIR ZIP
CODE DETERMINE THE AXIS OF REACH
THEY WOULD HAVE TO A RESOURCE.
NOW.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO ME
BECAUSE I WAS ONCE ONE OF THESE
KIDS.
WE TALK ABOUT SECOND CHANCES BUT
WHAT ABOUT THE CHILDREN THE
NEVER HAD A FIRST ONE TO BEGIN
WITH.
WHAT ABOUT THE KIDS I GREW UP IN
A HOME THOSE VOTED ABUSE
WHY WITNESSED ABUSE WERE I WAS
ABUSING THAT I WENT TO A SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT TOLD ME I WAS ALSO
GOING TO BE NOTHING?
AND THEN I WENT TO A SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT ASSUME.
THE EVERY I WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE
EVERYTHING ELSE FIGURED OUT
BECAUSE THE LACK OF RESOURCES
SHOWED ME THAT.
THE LACK OF RESOURCES TOLD ME
THAT WHATEVER IS HAPPENING IN
YOUR HOME IS NORMAL.
AND THIS IS NOT A PLACE TO COME
AND HELP YOU WITH THOSE ISSUES.
SO AS A CHILD TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHO I WAS OR WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN LIFE OR WHO
ARE HOW TO EVEN SURVIVE.
I FOUND MYSELF FALLING.
IN LINE WITH THE ONLY THING I
KNEW HOW TO DO WHICH WAS THE
GANGS THAT PROVIDED THE SUPPORT
AND THE LOVE THAT I THOUGHT
EXISTED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE I COULD NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO IN SCHOOLS SO WE TALK ABOUT
SAFETY AND PREVENTION.
IT'S IRONIC THAT THE KIDS THAT
ARE OFTENTIMES REAP THE MOST
REPEAT VICTIMS BUT THE KIDS ARE
OFTENTIMES THE MOST IN NEED OR
THE ONE THAT HAD THE LEAST.
AXIS CITIES RESOURCES.
OVER AND OVER RECEIVED ITS
SUFFERING.
SO I COME TODAY IN SUPPORT.
IN A BILL THAT I BELIEVE
PROVIDES.
ACCESS TO THE TRAUMA RECOVERY.
AND RESOURCES NEEDED FOR THEM TO
HAVE A FUTURE AND TO HAVE THAT
FIRST CHANCE THAT WE ALL
DESERVE.
YOU.
MEMBERS UMP MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MARTHA MERCHANT AND I'M WITH.
HEARTS HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS
RESPONSE TROHMAN SCHOOLS.
WHICH IS A MULTI TIERED SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT
THAT AIMS TO PREVENT.
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
TO INTERRUPT THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
AND THE IDEAS THAT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT MORE THERAPY WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS WHOLE
SCHOOL CHANGE A CHANGE IN THE
CULTURE OF THE SCHOOL SO THAT.
STUDENTS LIKE JAMES CAN.
GO TO SCHOOL AND FEEL LIKE THIS
IS A PLACE FOR ME THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE I CAN GET HELP THIS
IS A PLACE WHERE I CAN. A BECOME
THE BEST ME THAT I THAT I WANT
TO BE.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT AIMS AT.
RID.
.
IMPROVING.
EDUCATION FOR ALSO TEACHERS WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
.
THE.
ADDRESSING CHRONIC TRAUMA AND
STRESS ACROSS THE BOARD SO
THERE'S A.
A CULTURE SHIFT AT THE SCHOOL.
M. AND THAT.
.
THE IN THE ENVIRONMENT BECOMES A
SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND TEACHING
ENVIRONMENT. SO THAT PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A FIRST CHANCE OR
COMING FROM A PLACE WHERE THEY
NEED MORE THAN WHAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO GET AT HOME THEY CAN GET SOME
OF THAT AT SCHOOL SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT I'M SETTING UP MORE
THERAPY SPACES IT'S ABOUT.
CHANGING THE WAY THE SCHOOLS THE
KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
TRAUMA I'M EITHER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY BECAUSE WE ALSO KNOW
THE COMMUNITY VIOLENCE IS A
THING THAT HAPPENS TO KIDS WHO
MAY BE GROWING UP IN PERFECTLY
LOVING HOUSEHOLDS. AND I'M
FEELING LIKE.
WHAT I'M GOING THROUGH IS THE
NORM AND AND I SHOULD JUST BE
ABLE TO FIGURE IT OUT? IS
TERRIFYING TO CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE ANSWERS.
SO.
WE REALLY ARE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING CAPACITY IN SCHOOLS
WRAP IT UP YES WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILDING CAPACITY IN SCHOOLS AND
AND AND NOT JUST.
.
THERE BE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TROUBLE.
THANK YOU. OF ANY WITNESSES
INSOFAR OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
YOUR LITTLE AMONG FOLK ARE SOME
OTHER TIME IN AGAINST GANGS
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A LINEAR WITNESSES SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE COMICS
COMMENTS.
WE BEGIN BY SAYING THAT.
CLEARLY AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
OF THE PREMISE BEHIND YOUR BILL
HERE.
I WE WANT TO GIVE GREATER ACCESS
TO TREATMENT FOR ALL THOSE WHO
NEED IT.
I DO HOWEVER HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BREADTH OF THE BILL
AND SOME OF THE VERY BROAD
LANGUAGE.
THIS BILL TARGETS THE VICTIM'S
RESTITUTION FINES.
AS IT'S A. FUNDING SOURCE WHICH
IS PROBLEMATIC FOR TWO REASONS.
OF THE FUND IS DWINDLING
RAPIDLY.
AND RESEARCH INSOLVENCY IN JUST
A FEW SHORT YEARS.
AND THE BILL LANGUAGE DOES NOT
SPECIFY THE BOOKS BEING TREATED.
ARE TRULY VICTIMS OF CRIME.
WHICH LEADS TO PROBLEMS WITH
FEDERAL FUND MATCHING.
AND THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS.
ARE ANY OF.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER AND MISTER LACKEY YES.
I APPRECIATE BUT THE COMMENTS
AND WHERE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
TRIUMPH OF FIND A DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCE BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH THE THE
FRAMEWORK.
SO THAT WE HAVE THESE.
TRAUMA CENTERS AS A FORMER
TEACHER I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
CAN SIT THERE ALL DAY AND. I
ADVOCATE AND YOU KNOW I CAN
TEACH THAT THREE HOURS ALL DAY
LONG AND IF THE KIDS ARE NOT.
OPEN BECAUSE OF ANY TRAUMA OR
ANYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING IN
THEIR LIVES THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN EDUCATED.
GROUP OF KIDS ALL BUT SO I I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND WE
ARE LOOKING AT.
FIGURE ON THE DIFFERENT THE
DIFFERENT OF FUNDING SOURCES WE
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
PREPARATIONS ON.
IDENTIFYING WHAT THE BEST
SOURCES RIGHT NOW THIS IS WHAT
WE CAME UP WITH THEM BY JOB
HOPEFULLY THAT WHEN IT MOVES TO
PREPARATIONS WE CAN WORK ON.
IDENTIFYING AYE AYE AYE AN
ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THIS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND LET YOU CLOSING
YES THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I
WOULD.
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE AYE VOTE.
DID THE CHAIRS AND RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE.
SO YOU IS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON DRUM INFORMED CARE ON
ASUS OF SOMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND I EVEN HAD A RESOLUTION
POSTTRAUMATIC ST DISORDER TO
DEAL WITH WHAT'S GOING ON. WITH
PEOPLE IN THE INNER CITY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SINCE
WE HAVE THIS RATED OUR WHOLE
MENTAL HEALTH.
O. MENTAL HEALTH.
GROUPS BETTER IN SCHOOL THEY'RE
GONE NURSES
MEN OF PROFESSIONS PSYCHOLOGISTS
ON PSYCHOLOGIST WE DID JUST NOT
THERE ANYMORE BECAUSE OF BUDGET
CUTS.
AND SO I'M EVEN ASKING FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR PTSD
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
L. INDUCE YEARS KILLING HUNDREDS
OF MY OUT COUPLE OF MILLION AND.
SO I FELT LIKE I HAD A.
THE BRIGHT GIVE GRANTS FOR YES
THINGS THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE TAUGHT
AYE HUESO ADI LAWS ARE THE
FUNDING SOURCE BUT AB TWENTY
SEVEN KNOW WHEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
I CANNOT VOTING PATIO. W. AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
THAT MEASURE PATH POINT GIVING.
IF THERE ARAMBULA.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWELVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
GLAD YOU'RE RUNNING SUCH
EFFICIENT MEETINGS.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWELVE WHEELS AT
HAMLISCH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM AT THE BOARD OF STATE.
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS THAT
UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATION WILL GIVE CITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK FUNDING. FOR
DESPERATELY NEEDED PUBLIC SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU GOT IT TWICE SO WELL THEN AT
THAT POINT I'LL HAVE. A MOVE ON
AND HAVE MY SUPPORTERS PRESENT.
I THINK YOU TIME SHARING THINGS
ALL THIS WITH TOWNSEND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SINGER REALLY AND ORANGE CO. THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE WE HEAR ABOUT
WITH THEIR CITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS HOW THEIR POLICE
FACILITIES ARE INADEQUATE. AND
THAT THEY'RE JUST BURSTING FROM
THE SEEMS THEY'RE WORKING OUT OF
TRAILERS THEY'VE GOT EVIDENCE.
ANYWHERE THEY CAN THAT IT SO WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
TAKING A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AND
COMING UP WITH THIS APPROACH WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND IT WOULD THIS IS NOT
POSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE MAY CLOSE WITH ARAMBULA.
HUMBLY REQUEST YOUR IVA.
DOT CHAIRS ARE AGAIN I VOTES
BESSIE SINCE YOU GOT HOME MOTION
FROM BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS TOOK TO MOVE THE
BILL.
SEWER.
BUT MANY AYE VOTE.
AB TWENTY FOUR TOLD THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER I LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
CARILLO.
ATTY ALL AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
KIGHT OPENS KILEY SITE HERE
EITHER.
TING PATTERSON ARE ON THEIR WAY
UP.
AND WE HADN'T STARTING WITH
CONSENT YES.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE.
IF YOU WANT PRESENTED TO FALL.
OH YEAH.
NAT ON AB NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
QUIRK.
NO.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOW.
THAT MEASURE FAILS AT.
ROOM WHERE WE'RE BY UNANIMOUS
RUNNER.
IN CENTER RECONSIDERATION.
NUMBER FOUR LOW.
GET A RIGHT HANDED.
MOVING FAST TODAY.
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT QUIRK.
I'D AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
DO YOU WANT PRESENT MEMBERSHIP
QUIRK.
MAKE SURE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO QUIRK
.
SECOND.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO.
WOULD REQUIRE ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO LOG
RECOVERED CRIME GUN DATA INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AUTOMATED. A FIREARM SYSTEMS
AT THE CURRENT TIME IT READS
WITHIN THREE DAYS OF RECOVERY.
OUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE.
.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO DO THIS TO
SEE IF THEY NEED MORE TIME THAN
THAT AND IF SO WE WILL. NOT LOOK
INTO GRANTING THAT.
UP THIS BILL WILL ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO IN TO ISSUE A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S COMPLIANCE.
WITH LOCKING THIS INFORMATION
GUN TRACING IS A CRITICAL TOOL
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO IDENTIFY
CONTRACTING.
I ILLEGAL SALES HER SUSPICIONS
PATTERNS OF LOS FIREARMS USED TO
COMMIT CRIMES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW POLICE AND
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT CRIME GUN
INFORMATION OF THE.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
AUTOMATED FIREARM SYSTEM AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO.
WILL ENSURE DATA ON EVERY
FIREARM USED IN A CRIME
RECOVERED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. IS
LOGGED INTO DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S AUTOMATED.
FIREARM SYSTEM.
THIS WILL HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BETTER RECOGNIZE PATTERNS IN GUN
TRAFFICKING.
FIGURE OUT HAVE CRIMINALS ARE
GETTING THEIR HANDS ON THEM. AND
WORKED TO PREVENT ANOTHER
INNOCENT LIFE TO BE TAKEN TO
SHARE.
WITH ME TODAY IS AMANDA WILCOX
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE. AND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
BEGIN.
BOB THANK YOU I CAN BE BRIEF I'M
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF AMANDA
WILCOX AS OF SEVEN THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
GIFFORD'S LAW CENTER WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE ENTERING OF ALL. RECOVER
GUNS TO PROTECT THE CRYING GUNS
INTO ULTIMATELY ATF'S
TRACE IN CALIFORNIA WE DO THAT
FIRST. BY DATA BEING ENTERED
INTO DOJ'S AUTOMATED FIRED
SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN A PRIORITY
POLICY ISSUE FOR OUR NATIONAL
BRADY CAMPAIGN. AS WELL AS OUR
CHAPTERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
OUR COALITION IN CALIFORNIA.
TRACE IS IMPORTANT FOR FOR
REASONS
ONE IS TO GET LEADS.
.
INVESTIGATIVE LEADS ON
INDIVIDUAL CRIME GUNS
TWO IS TO IDENTIFY GUN
TRAFFICKING PATTERNS KNOW WHERE
COMMUNITIES COMING FROM AND ARE
THERE.
PARTICULAR GUN DEALERS SO
CALLED BAD APPLE GUN DEALERS
THAT SUPPLY SO MANY OF THESE
CRIME GUNS IN TWO THOUSAND IN
YEAR TWO THOUSAND I BELIEVE IT
WAS. TRACE DATA FOUND THAT ONE
GUN DEALER WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
HALF OF THE CRIME GUNS IN
OAKLAND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE PATTERNS AND WE
FORMER SHUT DOWN THOSE DEALERS.
THEN IN CALIFORNIA I'M GETTING
THAT INFORMATION INTO A F.*
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR ARMED
PROHIBITIVE PERSON SYSTEM
PROGRAM WHICH RELIES ON GOOD
DATA FOR CROSS CHECKING FIREARM
OWNERS IN A FS. WITH.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BECOME
PROHIBITED AND AS YOU KNOW DOJ
GOES TO DISARM THOSE PEOPLE WHAT
DOJ AS FINE AS THEY GO TO
DISARM.
A PERSON WHO'S IN APPS
AND THEY DISCOVER THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALREADY HAD BEGUN
BUT THEY DIDN'T AND HURT TO
SYSTEM SO IT REALLY INTERFERES
WITH THE EFFICIENCY OF OUR APPS
PROGRAM AND BRINGING DOWN THE
BACKLOG. IN THE FINALLY NEXT
YEAR OUR AMMO BACKGROUND CHECKS
SYSTEMS GOING INTO PLACE.
WHERE A FS THAT DATABASE IS
COMPARE WITH APPS OF SOMEONE HAS
A GUN REGISTERED TO THEM AND
THEY'RE NOT IN NAPS AND THEY'RE
GOOD TO GO AND FIND AMMUNITION
WELL THE PAY PERSON MAY NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE THE GUN IT SHOULD
NOT BE REGISTERED TO THEM? LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS IT SO AGAIN IF
THAT DATA IS NOT ACCURATE AND
KEPT UPDATED. OF THEIR COULD BE
IN RHODIA'S AMMUNITION CELL
SO WE WANT GOOD DATA IN DOJ
SYSTEMS WE WANT CRIME GUNS
TRACED SO WE CAN SOLVE THESE
CRIMES IDENTIFY. THE CORRUPT GUN
DEALERS.
SUCH IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUE IT
HAS BEEN LAW IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SHE'S.
CHAIR DEPARTMENTS ENTER THE DATA
THAT'S VERY SPOTTY IN OUR STATE
SOME DO SOME DON'T ALL. OUR IN
HOUSE AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE THE
REQUIREMENT THEY MAY BUT THEY DO
NOT HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY WE WANT
ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
DO THIS. AND WE WANT OUGHT TO BE
DONE IN A TIMELY WAY SO THE
INFORMATION'S MORE ACTIONABLE
ALSO I KNOW IT'S HUMAN NATURE IF
THERE'S NO TIMELINE YOU CAN DO
IT ANYTIME SOMETIMES YOU NEVER
DO IT.
SO WE WANT OUR INCREASED TRACING
IN OUR STATE. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME ORGANIZATION THE MISS MARY
HYATT CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ARE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA. ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF RECORDS
SUPERVISORS AND THESE ARE THE
FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY DO ENTER THIS
INFORMATION INTO THE SYSTEM AYE
WE WANT I THINK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRKY OUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THIS OFFICE TO CHANGE IT
TIMELINE FROM THREE DAYS TO
SEVEN DAYS. SEVEN BUSINESS DAYS
THAT WILL ALLOW.
DOES TECHNICIANS WHO ENTERED
THIS INFORMATION TO A DATABASE
TO HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO DO SO
I THE THREE DAY AND IT WAS A
VERY SHORT TIME PERIOD
ESPECIALLY IF IT FALLS ON A
THREE DAY WEEKEND OR HOLIDAYS
AND SUCH. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WEEKLY WITH THE POLICY OF THIS
ON MEASURE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN COMPLY WITH IT
SO WE I THINK THAT MEMBER AND
OUT ONCE A DAY AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKING WE WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE ALL BE TAKING THURMOND.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER. WITNESSES SAN
SUPPORT OUR OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER QUIRK.
BOB WILL BE TAKING THAT DATA.
AMENDMENT AS SUGGESTED FROM
THREE DAYS TO SEVEN BUSINESS
DAYS WERE HAPPY TO DO THAT.
pOUT BY MISS WILCOX IS TO HAVE A
TIME.
SO THE PEOPLE CAN CHECK A BOX
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
TIME.
PEOPLE ARE BUSY AND IT JUST MAY
NOT HAPPEN AND THAT'S THE WHOLE
INTENT OF THE BILL SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO.
TO WORK WITH THE RECORD KEEPERS.
THANK YOU MISCHIEF RECOMMENDED
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY TALKING TO
PEOPLE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT.
A LAW THAT WE COME UP WITH AND
THEY AGREE WITH WHAT WE'RE
DEALING AND THEY'VE GIVEN US.
SOME ASSURANCES THAT THEY CAN
GET IT DONE DESIST AWAY. EVERY
BILLS SHOULD BE DONE SO.
I AM TUESDAY AFTER GLEE AS
EVERYONE FOR AN AYE VOTE.
BUT AB TWENTY TO TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JOBS ARE I LACKEY. LACKEY I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
SO MISTER HARPER.
YOU
SIGNED A LITTLE EARLIER. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THREE.
AND IF I MAY ASK THE CHAIR WE
HAD THE A SHARE FROM SHASTA
COUNTY ARRIVE WITH US WOULD IT.
BE OKAY WITH THE CHAIR TO HAVE
THREE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
SHOULD WE LIMIT TO HAVE FOUR
MINUTES AND.
THAT'S IT MEN SO WHATEVER WAY
YOU WANT TO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY THREE THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE THE MICROSCOPIC
REQUIREMENT FOR NEW MODEL
HANDGUNS TO BE CERTIFIED FOR
SALE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MICROSCOPIC A HANDGUN INVOLVES
THE IMPRINTING OF A MICROSCOPIC
ARRAY OF CHARACTERS THAT
IDENTIFY THE MAKE MODEL AND
SERIAL NUMBER OF THE HANDGUN.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY REQUIRES
THAT A HANDGUN IS IN PREGNANT
CHORE MORE PLACES ON THE
INTERIOR SERVICE OR ON THE
WORKING PART OF THE GUN.
STATE ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
IDENTIFYING CHARACTERS ARE
TRANSFERRED ONTO EACH CARTRIDGE
CASE WHEN THE FIREARM INSPIRED.
WHEN THIS OUT WELL THIS SOUNDS
LIKE A GREAT WAY TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK DOWN FIREARMS WITH THE
BULLETS THEY'RE SHOT FROM THEM
THE PROBLEMS AT THE MICROSCOPIC
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT VIABLE. THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE MICROSTATE
APPEAR TWICE ON THE FIREARMS
CASING IS PRACTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO ACCOMPLISH.
IN ADDITION SCIENCES CONFIRMED
THAT THE MARKS LEFT BY THE
INTERNAL COMPONENTS OF A GUN
THAT ARE ALTERED FROM NORMAL USE
WHICH MAKES THE MICROSCOPIC
USELESS.
IF TECHNOLOGY WAS BOUGHT AT THE
TECHNOLOGY WAS VIABLE A CRIMINAL
COULD EASILY FILED DOWN THE
MARKER STAMP AND ELIMINATE ITS
PURPOSE.
FOR THE REASONS FOR THESE
REASONS GUN MANUFACTURERS HAVE
YET TO EVEN IMPLEMENT THIS
TECHNOLOGY SINCE NEW HANDGUNS
ARE UNABLE TO BE MICRO STAMPED
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CALIFORNIA
LAW FOR AT LEAST THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. THAT HAS A LIMITED A BILL
A LIMITED THE ABILITY FOR
CONSUMERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO EXERCISE AND FIND
THEIR OF FIND A FIREARM FOR
THEIR PERSONAL PROTECTION.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED TO EXPAND
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
RELIABLE HANDGUNS WHILE
PRESERVING CURRENT SAFE HANDGUN
CERTIFICATIONS WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY THREE. IS DAN READ FROM
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
SAM PRAISE FROM THE DONORS ARE
GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA AS A
STATED A.
TOM BUT CINCO THE SHERIFF CORNER
OF SHASTA COUNTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE
AND READ. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEANT FOR. US BRING
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS HE STATED MICRO
STEPPING TECHNOLOGY. HAS SERVED
AS A BAND AIDS STYMIED.
THE AVAILABILITY OF NEW MODEL
SEMI AUTOMATIC FIREARMS TO THE
HANDGUN ROSTER SINCE IT WAS
CERTIFIED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
NO MANUFACTURE HAS IMPLEMENTED
THIS THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND STUDIES HAVE CONSISTENTLY
CONCLUDED THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
NOT VIABLE EVEN THE.
THE CREATOR IN THE PATENT
HOLDER OF THIS TECHNOLOGY AYE MR
LUSARDI HIMSELF ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS.
REGARDING BOTH THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS IS WELL AS PRODUCTION
COSTS IN THE DATABASE MANAGEMENT
THAT WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH
MICROSCOPIC.
YOU SEAT OF IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE
AS YES ENGRAVING.
THE MAKE MODEL SERIAL NUMBER
CALDERON THE FIRING PIN THESE
HAVE TO BE OPTIMIZED AND EVEN
IN.
LABORATORY CONDITIONS WITH
SOPHISTICATED MICROSCOPES THIS
TECHNOLOGY WAS NOT RELIABLY
IMPRINTING AND THAT ONE OF THE
STUDIES EVEN TALKS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU NEED.
POSSIBLY TEN SHELL CASINGS TO
EVEN COME UP WITH THE FULL CODE
THAT WENT ALONG AND TO IDENTIFY
DID THE FIREARM.
AND MOST FOR A CRIME I JUST
DON'T HAVE THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN AGAIN.
IT'S.
IT'S JUST NOT RELIABLE EVEN IN
THOSE OPTIMIZE SITUATIONS AND
CAN EASILY BE DEFEATED WITH WITH
A FILE OR SOME HOUSEHOLD GOOD
WITH THE SHERIFF WILL TALK
ABOUT.
CALIFORNIANS WHO SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO A LOT THAT'S JUST NOT
RELIABLE.
AND FOR THAT WE THINK THERE
ASSEMBLYMAN.
FOR BRINGING THIS AND WE URGE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BOARD THOMAS CYCLE CHEST
COUNTY SHERIFF. I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ENCOURAGING AYE VOTE AS
THE.
WITNESS AND ALTER HAVE STATED
MANY REASONS FOR THIS IT ALSO
LIMITS THE ABILITY FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO PROVIDE
FIREARMS. TO THE CITIZENS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND FOR CITIZENS
TO OBTAIN THE FIREARMS OF THE
MICRO STAMPING IS EASILY
DEFEATED EITHER JUST DUE TO
NORMAL WEAR AND TEAR. ON THE END
OF A FIRING PIN WHICH IS LIKE
THE DIAMETER OF A PIECE OF THE
PENCIL LEAD. THAT IT CAN ALSO BE
INTENSELY REMOVED VERY EASILY
WITH ABRASIVE SUCH AS EMERY
CLOTH OR FILE OR A FINGERNAIL
FILE. YOU'D ALSO SEED A CRIME
SCENE WITH OBTAINING MICRO
STAMPED. BRASS.
LEAVING IT THERE TO BELIEVE SOME
TYPE OF. OF REASONABLE DOUBT OF
WHO COMMITTED THAT CRIME AND SO
FOR THESE REASONS AND OTHERS.
IF THEY WANTED TO COMMIT A
CRIME THEY COULD USE A REVOLVER
WHICH DOES NOT. EL EXPEL THE
BRASS INTO A CRIME SCENE BUT
STILL STAYS WITHIN THE CYLINDER
SO FOR THESE REASONS AYE
ENCOURAGING AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
I THINK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GIVEN LIMITED TIME I WANNA PUT
OUT A COUPLE OF THINGS
MANUFACTURES HAVE NOT REJECTED
THE USE OF THEM. THEY SAY THAT
IF THEY DO USE IT BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE PROBLEMS
WITH THAT THEY COULD BE SUED OUT
OF EXISTENCE IF THEY MAKE ONE
MISTAKE. IMPAIRING HIM A A
FIRING PIN TO A PARTICULAR
FRAME.
IF.
IN THE MANUFACTURING PROCESS IN
THE ASSEMBLY PROCESS IN
CUSTOMIZING PROCESS THOSE THINGS
GET MESSED UP THEY'RE GOING TO
BE SUED OUT OF EXISTENCE.
NO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
BY THE GUNS THAT DON'T HAVE THIS
THAT ALL THE CITIZENS DON'T.
CANNOT GET BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ON THE APPROVED LIST BECAUSE OF
MICRO STAMPING.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SAFER MORE
EFFICIENT MORE COST EFFECTIVE.
CITIZENS SHOULD BE AFFORDED THE
SAME.
.
PRIVILEGE OR RIGHT MICHAEL
STAMPING IS ONE TWENTY SIX THAT
THICKNESS OF A HAIR. THAT'S WHAT
THE IMPRESSION IS ON THE FIRING
PIN.
IT CAN BE REMOVED VERY EASILY IT
REMOVES ITSELF.
WITH CONTINUED USE.
AND THEN IT'S IT'S IT'S GONE BUT
THAT HAS PREVENTED.
SAFE. INEXPENSIVE.
OUR MODERN FIREARMS FROM BEING
ABLE TO BE SOLD THEY STILL HAVE
THAT LOADED CHAMBER INDICATORS
MAGAZINE DISCONNECT THEY HAVE TO
BE DROPPED THAT SIX FEET ON
CONCRETE THEY CAN ACCIDENTALLY
GO OFF. THEIR VERY SAFE GUNS AND
THIS PROVISION THAT REQUIRES A
TECHNOLOGY THAT NOBODY.
IN THOUGH WORLD USES.
AS A MATTER OF FACT NO
MANUFACTURE HAS PURCHASED THE
MILLION DOLLAR MACHINERY THAT IT
WHICH IS REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
HAVE THIS CAPABILITY AND
FINALLY.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
TO FOLLOW THIS LAW BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT. IMPRESS THAT.
EVEN IF YOU COULD TO IT
SUCCESSFULLY YOU CANNOT
IMPRESSIVE IN TWO DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS ON A CASE.
IT CANNOT BE DONE.
THAT'S WHY.
LIZOTTE ABANDONED HIS PATENT
WHICH MADE IT AVAILABLE FOR FOR
THE OF THE.
ODD.
.
AT AT CERTIFICATION BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THOSE
REASONS SEN AND OTHERS WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED WE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL CONSIDER THIS MEASURE
WHERE SUPPORT. THAT IT'S A RARE
OCCASION AWARENESS ALVARADO
WHERE WE'RE HERE AND.
ASK YOUR SUPPORT AND IF WE GET
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
TECHNOLOGIES WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
ARE ANY OHER.
MEMBERS AND ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT NAMING ORGANIZATION OR
GRIFFITH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU TERM THANK YOU. A ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THEN AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT COME
VIOLENCE TODDLERS ARE ACTUALLY
ABANDON THE PATENT BECAUSE HE
SAW THE PUBLIC SAFETY BENEFITS
AND HE WANTED TO BE IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN. HE WAS NOT
INTERESTED IN MAKING MONEY TO.
MONEY OFF OF THIS
IT TOOK AWHILE TO GET THE
PATENTS UNENCUMBERED BECAUSE I'M
THE NOTES TO HIM THE GUN LOBBY
RENEW THE PATENT.
SO THAT'S THE HISTORY ON THAT
ALLOW THESE ARGUMENTS I HEARD
WHEN WE FIRST PASSED THE BILL IS
A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN'S WHEN IT WAS
ENACTED.
AT THAT TIME WE MADE THE POINT
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF. GUN CRIME
TWO WORDS ON SOFT PARTICULARLY
AFTER DRIVE BY SHOOTINGS WHERE
THE ONLY EVIDENCE LEFT ARE WHERE
THE BULLET CASINGS THE CARTRIDGE
CASINGS LEFT AT THE CRIME SCENE.
AND THE IDEA IS TO HAVE
INTENTIONAL MARKS THAT WILL LINK
THOSE CASINGS ARE TO THE GUN
WHERE THEN THE. THE RANDOM.
BALLISTIC EVIDENCE THAT WOULD
BE THERE OTHERWISE.
AND THAT NEED OF COURSE TO SOFT
ON CRIME IS STILL THERE.
ARMY MY ITEM WHEN.
THAT LEGISLATION WAS PASSED TO
REQUIRE NEW HANDGUNS NEW MODELS
OF HANDGUNS TO HAVE CHAMBER LOAD
INDICATORS A MAGAZINE DISCONNECT
AND THE GUN DESERVES INDUSTRY
SAID WE CANNOT DO IT. AND WE
WILL NOT DO IT AND THEY DIDN'T
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS AND THEN
FINALLY ONE MANUFACTURE DECIDED
TO AND THEN WE SAW THOSE KIND
GUNS COME ONLINE.
I SUSPECT THIS WILL BE THE SAME
THING BUT WE'LL SEE. ARE THIS IS
RIGHT NOW PENDING IN THE COURT
ABOUT WHETHER.
THE CAN BE DONE OR NOT MY
SUGGESTION IS TO LET THE COURTS
PROCESS PLAY OUT LET THEM
DECIDE.
BUT I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY'RE SUCH RESISTANCE TO
ADDING THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
HELP US SOLVE CRIME AND SAVE
LIVES ASK YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
LEADING THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
AMANDA COULD DO WAS WILCOX YOU
STAY ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER QUIRK.
YES I'M.
MS WILCOX ARM.
WHAT ABOUT THIS QUESTION THAT
THE TIME STAMP CAN BE FILED OFF?
IT PROBABLY CAN.
I MEAN THERE'S WELL LIGHTED
THAT.
IT IS A REAL CONCERN WELL YOU
KNOW WATCHING THAT WOULD BE PART
OF THE COURT CASE.
YOU KNOW I REMEMBER HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE NAY TALKED
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF TIMES A
CRIMINAL LEAVES A CRIME SCENE
WITHOUT REMOVING THEIR LICENSE
PLATES THERE'S THE ARGUMENT THAT
PEOPLE GO TO. GO.
.
YOU KNOW SCOOP UP.
CASINGS AND ARRANGE THEN TAKE
IMPLANET AT A CRIME SCENE I MEAN
I SUPPOSE THOSE THINGS COULD
HAPPEN. GENERALLY CRIMINALS
DON'T TAKE THAT.
NO BAD AT THAT KIND OF ACTION TO
HAVE.
TO EVADE DETECTION BUT SURE I
THINK IT COULD BE DEFERRED
DEFEATED THAT WAY.
IF SOMEONE TOOK THAT EFFORT.
BUT I MEAN THAT'S TRUE WITH LOTS
OF THINGS.
WELL AGAIN IT SEEMS THIS IS A
VERY TECHNICAL QUESTION THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ANSWER TO DAY
AND I DO SUGGEST THAT WE LEAVE
IT TO THE COURT'S THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAKE CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MISTER CHAIR. I.
WHEN I LEFT UP TO THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS I'M OF THE
BELIEVER THAT LEGISLATION IS
PREFERABLE TO LITIGATION IN
TERMS OF DECIDING POLICY
CHOICES.
THE REASON FOR THIS PER OUR
REASON FOR THIS BILL IS SIMPLE.
I THE MICROSTATE UPPING
REQUIREMENT WAS PASSED BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN ARE BASED
ON HIGH HOPES BUT UNFORTUNATELY
TECHNOLOGY HASN'T BARED OUT.
THE MICR STAMPING REQUIREMENT
CHILLS MARKET FORCES AND LIMITS
THE POOL TECHNOLOGY.
TO OF TECHNOLOGICALLY SUPERIOR
FIREARMS TO CALIFORNIANS
THE BILL REVERSE THIS THE
REMOVAL OF THE MICROSCOPIC
MANDATE WILL EXPAND THE
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE.
RELIABLE.
HANDGUNS WHILE PRESERVING.
CURRENT SAFE HANDGUN
CERTIFICATIONS
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL THOSE
WHO SPOKE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THEIR
PERSPECTIVES ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND OF THIS.
ISSUE THEY CAN EASILY BE
RESOLVED BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
CALIFORNIA'S MADE IT SAFER AND
MORE RELIABLE HANDGUNS THAT CAN
BE OUR CALIFORNIA SHOULD MAKE
IT.
SAFER MAKE SAFER MORE LEVEL
HANDGUNS.
TO BE ABLE TO BE SOLD HERE FOR
PERSONAL PROTECTION.
REQUIREMENT THE HANDGUNS BE
MICRO STAMPED IS SIMPLY NOT
POSSIBLE IN TODAY'S MARKET WITH
TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY.
THIS BILL WILL LIMIT THE
MICROSTATE BANG REQUIREMENT
ALLOW NEWER AND SAFER HANDGUNS
TO BE SOLD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE IN THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
AND UP.
DID NOT I APPRECIATE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT AND NOT THINK
MISTER QUIRK HAS A HAS A VALID.
QUESTION ON YOUR YOUR STATEMENT
ABOUT LEGISLATION VERSUS COURT
ORDERS.
IF IT WASN'T FOR BROWN VERSUS
BOARD OF EDUCATION OVEN MONEY
USC. ITSELF SOMETIMES A COURT
CASES.
BETTER THAT LEGISLATION.
AND SO I'M GONNA RECOMMEND NO
VOTE BECAUSE I ALSO WANT COURT
CASE TO PAN OUT. I THINK THEY'RE
GOING INTO DETAIL WHICH IS WHAT
MR QUIRK IS TALKING ABOUT.
FIVE MANUFACTURING WAS NOT TO
MEET DONE.
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF FILING.
.
KUTCHER FILING IS TO SHIFT INTO
DEFILING GUNS RIGHT NOW FILING
OFF DHEA. THAT THAT SERIAL
NUMBER SO THAT.
THAT ENOUGH CRIME FLAT DUTCH.
DONE ANYWAY AND WE STILL
REQUIRE.
SERIAL NUMBERS ON GUNS WE
DIDN'T ABANDON SO OF.
UNREGULATED A NO VOTE AND.
MCCULLOUGH RULE.
IT'S NO MOST.
YEAH.
IT WAS A BIT.
IT WAS NOT DELIBERATE. AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
ON AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THREE.
GOTTA YOUR.
GALIANO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SOME NEVER KNOW.
A MEASURE PASSES.
A FAILED FROM TARA FAILED OPEN
SO I KNOW.
IT I I DID THE SAME THING SO.
MR VIA MY GOOD FRIEND WE'RE.
WHAT ALTERNATE UNIVERSES TODAY?
YOU'RE OF HERE WITH THAT WITH
YOUR A CONSIDERATION LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK RECONSIDERATION
IF A LOT GRANTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
SO.
I MISTER KILEY HE AT HIS A
WITNESS THAT NEEDS TO GO. AND.
AND I'M PASS THROUGH BECAUSE I
NEED TO GO PRESENT COULD
COMMITTEE. SOMA PASS IT TO
MISTER LACKEY.
AND.
I'M SORRY. THEY ALSO GOOD WOOD
MISTER TING.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING AT MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FIFTY SIX IS A VITAL
MEASURE TO COMPLEMENT OTHER
IMPORTANT STEPS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN TO COMBAT
HUMAN SEX TRAFFICKING.
SEX TRAFFICKING IS ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST RAPIDLY SPREADING
CRIMES AND THIS PARTICULARLY
PREVALENT IN CALIFORNIA. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
CASES OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
REPORTED IN CALIFORNIA AND OF
THOSE CASES ONE THOUSAND FIFTY
ONE. WERE SEX TRAFFICKING CASES
IN SOME COUNTIES THE CRIME IS
GROWING AT A NEAR EPIDEMIC RATE.
THE GROWTH OF THESE NUMBERS HAS
PERHAPS BEEN AIDED BY OUR
CRIMINAL CODES COUNTERINTUITIVE
TREATMENT OF THIS DEVASTATING
CRIME.
HUMAN SEX TRAFFICKING IS AN
OFFENSE WITH VIOLENCE AT ITS
CORE YET IT IS NOT CONSIDERED A
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT CRIME UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY SEX
TRAFFICKERS COULD BE RELEASED
FROM PRISON AFTER SERVING ONLY
HALF THEIR SENTENCE
IT ALSO MEANS THE RELEASED AFTER
ONLY SERVING A SENTENCE FOR ONE
VICTIM. REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
VICTIMS THERE WERE CONVICTED OF
TRAFFICKING.
AB TWO THREE FIVE SIX WOULD FIX
THIS ANOMALY WOULD SIMPLY ADD A
SEX TRAFFICKING TO THE LIST OF
CRIMES THEY'RE CONSIDERED. A
VIOLENT FELONY I WOULD I THINK
SENATOR GALGIANI FOR JOINING ME
AS A CO AUTHOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
JOINING YOU TODAY ARE WAS AT
SUITOR WITH THE EL DORADO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WHERE
SHE IS THE TEAM LEADER. FOR THE
SPECIAL VICTIMS UNIT IN CHARGE
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS WELL AS
I CRISTINA DUARTE WITH STAND UP
PLUS.
MAY I PROCEED THINK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR HEARING US
TODAY.
NO SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH SICK SEX
TRAFFICKING WITH.
SEX CASES INVOLVING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS ON OUR STATE
THERE'S BEEN WONDERFUL NEW LAWS
ON EDUCATION AND TRAINING
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE FOR
VICTIMS. BUT THAT'S ONLY PART OF
THE SIX THE SOLUTION AND IF WE
DON'T.
START TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN IT KEEP THE ACTUAL
TRAFFICKERS TO DO THEIR TIME
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY SENTENCED
TO. THIS CYCLE OF VIOLENCE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THESE TRAFFICKERS
BECAUSE THESE VICTIMS ARE NOT
HAVING TIME TO.
GET LIFE SKILLS THEY'RE NOT
HAVING THEIR STILL BEING
CONTROLLED BY THE TRAFFICKERS IN
PRINT IN PRISON IN JAIL WHERE
THEY ARE EVERY CASE THAT I SEE
THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE
REACHING OUT. SO THESE VICTIMS
DO NOT HAVE FAITH IN OUR SYSTEM
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO COOPERATE
AT INITIALLY.
SOME NOT ALL THEY'RE HAVING
VERY DIFFICULT TIMES BELIEVING
IN THE FAITH THAT THIS PERSON IS
REALLY GOING TO BE LIKE THAT LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. IF A
PERSON WHO IS CONVICTED OF SEX
TRAFFICKING IS SENTENCED TO
EIGHT YEARS IN STATE PRISON.
THERE OUT IN FOUR YEARS.
VICTIMS NO THAT'S THE MARCY'S
LAUNCHERS THAT ALL VICTIMS ARE
TOLD AND GIVEN THIS INFORMATION
UPON.
A DISPOSITION OR A GUILTY
CONVICTION.
NOW YOU TAKE THAT SAME PERSON
AND NOW YOU HAVE THREE VICTIMS
FOR FIVE IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF IF
THREE VICTIM CASE.
.
THAT TAKEN THAT'S BLOW TERM OF
EIGHT YEARS AND YOU ADD THOSE
OTHER TWO VICTIMS ON THAT BE
ABOUT SEVENTEEN YEARS AND FOUR
MONTHS.
THAT TRAFFICKER IS STILL
ELIGIBLE FOR.
RELEASE AFTER FOUR YEARS
AND THESE ARE THE FACTS THAT WE
HAVE TO TELL.
VICTIMS AND TRYINGTO CONVINCE
THEM TO COOPERATE WITH POLICE
IT'S VERY DAUNTING SITUATION AND
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY IN FEAR FOR
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR SAFETY AND
NOT WANTING TO COME FORWARD.
IF THIS IS A VIOLENT FELONY THAT
CHANGES THAT IT MAKES THEM BE
ABLE TO.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THEIR SENTENCE
AND SET A FIFTY PERCENT ANOTHER
KEY VALUABLE POINT THAT MAKING
THIS A VIOLENT FELONY CHANGES.
AS.
AS A GENERAL RULE PROSECUTORS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY IF THEY'RE
UNABLE TO PROCEED AT THE END OF.
WHEN IT'S TIME TO GO TO TRIAL
WITHIN STATUTORY TIMELINES ON A
FELONY. THEY GET TWO CHANCES
THEY CAN I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REFILE UNDER CURRENT LAW. A
VIOLENT FELONY HOWEVER YOU HAVE
A THIRD CHANCE.
AS A PROSECUTOR IF THEY'RE
UNABLE TO PROCEED THESE. HOW
MANY HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES
SPECIALLY INVOLVING SEX
TRAFFICKED VICTIMS ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIND ARE VICTIMS
THEY'RE FROM OUT NAY OF THEM ARE
HOMELESS THEY'RE HAVING IN
SHELTERS? TAKES A LOT OF TIME
MANY MANY CONVERSATIONS TO GAIN
THE TRUST OF THAT THEY SHARE
WITH US THAT THEY TELL US WHAT'S
HAPPENING. AND THESE TIME
CONSTRAINTS WHICH ARE GOOD TIME
RESTRAINTS FOR STATUTORY REASONS
FOR TO PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE
ACCUSED BUT TO ALLOW US THAT
THIRD CHANCE FOR MAKING THIS A
VIOLENT FELONY WOULD BE VERY
CRITICAL. IN THE OVERALL
SOLUTION TO HOW TO COMBAT THIS
PROBLEM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME IN MY CURRENT PRESENTS THE
POSITION RIGHT NOW AS A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OUTREACH COORDINATOR
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS AS WELL AS SUPPORT THEM
ONE ON ONE. TO THEIR JOURNEY AND
IN THIS TIME I HAVE HEARD MANY
STORIES ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE
ABOUT THE THE VIOLENCE THAT THEY
HAVE EXPERIENCED A. I'M ABOUT
THE TRAUMA ABOUT THE FEARS THAT
THEY HAVE THE BARRIERS THAT THEY
HAVE.
AND A THESE BARRIERS THAT THEY
BRING UP THEY DO OFTEN INCLUDE
OR THEY COME UP WHEN WE ARE
TALKING TO THEM ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD WITH PROSECUTION WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH THIS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN ORDER. TO
HAVE A SOLID CASE SO THAT THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROSECUTION AND ENSURE THAT
THEIR TRAFFICKER IS PUT INTO. A
PRISON AND THAT TIME IS SERVED
AND THERE ARE MANY BARRIERS AND
TOO MANY TO STATE FOR TIME.
CONSTRAINTS TODAY BUT ONE THAT
COMES UP TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THAT WAS JUST STATE IT IS TIME
THE TIME THAT THIS PROCESS
TAKES.
AS WELL AS THE TIME OF THE
SENTENCING THAT WHEN EVERYTHING
IS SAID AND DONE SO TODAY I
SPEAK IN HOPES TO.
HELP CONTINUE WITH THE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE MADE NOT ONLY TO
HOLD THE PERPETRATORS FULLY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR CRIMES BUT
EVEN MORE SO SO THAT WE AS
SOCIETY STAND BEHIND OUR WORDS.
AND REALLY PUT LAWS IN ACTIONS
BEHIND WHAT WE ARE SAYING I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT NOW
THAT WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY AS
A COMMUNITY AS A SOCIETY TO HEAR
FROM TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND
HEAR THEIR EXPERIENCES. IT'S
FAIR AND JUST TO SAY THAT IT IS
A CRIME OF VIOLENCE THEY
EXPERIENCE A LOT OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST THEMSELVES. AND SO IT'S
FAIR JUST TO SAY THAT WE NEED TO
CALL IT WHAT IT IS WHEN WE START
CALLING A CRIME AND PUTTING THAT
TITLE TO IT THAT IT DESERVES. I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHEN CHANGE CAN
BE MADE SO I FIRST JUST SAYING
WHAT IT IS AND THAT WILL SPEAK
VOLUMES HE'LL SPEAK VOLUMES TO
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED THE
TRAFFICKER AS WELL AS THE
VICTIM.
IT HELPS TO CONFIRM TO THEM YES
WE SEE THAT YOU'R A VICTIM THIS
IS UNFAIR AND WE ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT YOU. I RECENTLY
SUPPORTED A CLIENT THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS OF PROSECUTION OF
HER TRAFFICKER AND BY ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED SHE WAS VERY A
COOPERATIVE SHE WANTED TO WORK
WITH THE DA SHE WANTED TO WORK
WITH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT HER TRAFFICKER
WAS PUT INTO JAIL.
AND FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
EVEN THOUGH SHE HAD TO DEAL WITH
HER OWN TRAUMA IN TRYING TO GT
SAFE AND THINK ABOUT HER OWN
SAFETY NOT ONLY IN THE MOMENT
THAT HER WELL BEING A LONG TERM
MOVING FORWARD BUILDING THE LIFE
THAT SHE DESERVED.
FROM THE MOMENT THAT HE WAS
ARRESTED EVEN AFTER HE WAS
SENTENCED AND TRANSFERRED TO
WHERE HE WAS GOING TO BE
SPENDING HIS TIME HE CONTINUE TO
REACH OUT TO HER TO THREATEN TO
HURT TO THREATEN HER FAMILY
MEMBERS. TO CONTACT HER ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND SO ALL THAT
THAT DID WAS NOT ONLY CONFIRMED
HER THE FEARS THAT SHE HAD WERE
ALIVE AND VALID BUT IT ALSO
CHANGED HER TIMELINE SHE KNEW.
THAT HE WAS IN CONTROL STILL
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS LOCKED UP AND
NOT VERY SOON BECAUSE THE PLEA
THAT HE DID ACCEPT THAT HE WOULD
BE GETTING THAT HE WOULD BE
GETTING OUT. SO I THINK THAT IF
AS A COMMUNITY WE THINK IT'S
HARD TO HEAR THE STORIES AND
IT'S CHALLENGING TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS. TO TRY TO HELP THESE
VICTIMS THAT WE CAN TAKE A
MINUTE JUST TO THINK HOW MUCH
HARDER IS THAT FOR THE VICTIMS
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED THESE
STORIES AND THESE EXPERIENCES TO
MOVE FORWARD AND THAT IF WHAT WE
CAN GIVE THEM. IS MORE TIME THAN
I THINK THAT IS VERY FAIR.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IT'S PART.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SHARPER FOR
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY SIX.
BY ADDING NEWMAN SEX TRAFFICKING
TO THE LIST OF VIOLENT FELONIES
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX WOULD
PERPETUATE CALIFORNIA'S
EXPENSIVE AND INEFFECTIVE OVER
RELIANCE ON INCARCERATION. IN
DIRECT CONTRADICTION TO WHAT THE
VOTERS INTENDED WHEN THEY VOTED
FOR PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX ALSO
SINGLES OUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
A CRIME FOR WHICH INCREASED
PENALTIES UP TO FIFTEEN TO LIFE
HAVE JUST RECENTLY GONE INTO
EFFECT.
AND IT WOULD MAKE SEX
TRAFFICKING A STRIKE EXPANDING
THE SCOPE OF THAT LAW TO FURTHER
SET BACK THE CLOCK AND KEEP MORE
PEOPLE BEHIND BARS FOR FAR
LONGER.
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT FIXES A
MISTAKE THE OPPONENTS OF PROP
FIFTY SEVEN EXPRESSLY POINTED TO
HUMAN SEX TRAFFICKING AMONG
OTHER CRIMES. IN ARGUING AGAINST
THE PROPOSITION.
THE VOTERS DIDN'T BUY IT BECAUSE
THEY UNDERSTOOD THAT THE CHOICE
THEY WERE MAKING WAS WHAT WAS
NEEDED TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
PRISON COSTS.
THERE ARE WAYS TO COMBAT HUMAN
SEX TRAFFICKING WE DON'T DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF TIME SERVED FOR IT. AS
WOULD HAPPEN UNDER THIS BILL IS
THE WAY TO DO THAT.
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PRISONERS
AND THE COST OF INCARCERATING
THEM IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IF
CRIME BY CRIME THE LEGISLATURE
RECLASSIFIED OFFENSES SO AS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
OFFENDERS MUST SIR. WE ARCHER NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SIX.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY COME MITCHELL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE COURT YES I AM I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE IN THREE STRIKES PERIOD.
SO I WILL BE VOTING FOR YOUR
BILL.
KEN.
EXCUSE ME THERE'S ONE MORE
WITNESS THAT WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT CALLING YOU.
SO SORRY IT ROSA CABRERA BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE WAS MEN OF COLOR
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
KILLING PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND THANK YOU TO AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO OUR
ATTENTION AS WELL AS THE
WITNESSES TODAY.
I THINK FOR A LOT OF THOSE THREE
STRIKES ARE PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN HOWELL.
IT'S IMPACTED PRIMARILY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
.
BLACK MEN LATINO MEN ARE.
INCARCERATED AT DIFFERENT RATES
ACROSS OUR STATE AND ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY.
HOWEVER IT IT BOTHERS ME THAT
CRIMES THAT ARE COMMITTED
AGAINST WOMEN WHICH ARE WOMEN
ARE PREDOMINANTLY THE THE
VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING. ARE
NOT SEEN AS VIOLENT.
AND THE FACT THAT.
THESE CRIMES ARE COMMITTED OVER
AND OVER AND OVER TO A PERSON'S
BODY.
I THINK SAYS A LOT ABOUT.
HOW WE MANAGE OUR OUR
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
CONSIDER TO BE VIOLENT CRIMES?
AND FOR HOPE. TO.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY
ULTIMATELY WHILE.
SEX TRAFFICKING OCCURS TO MOSTLY
WOMEN. IT ALSO OCCURS TO MEN.
AND THE BEAT GOES BEYOND GENDER.
AND IT GOES BEYOND AGE
SINCE WE KNOW A LOT OF VICTIMS
ARE UNDER AGE AS WELL.
SO WHILE I DO HAVE SOME
RESERVATIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS MEANS I THINK.
I WILL BE VOTING YES BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST WOMEN PREDOMINANTLY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
VIOLENCE SEX.
I.
THE TRAFFICKING SO VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE FOR OUR STATE.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
SERIOUS ISSUE ACROSS OUR COUNTRY
ANNA'S.
JUST ON A SIDE NOTE I THINK
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN ALLEN LOS ANGELES
SPECIFICALLY.
IS WHEN THE OLYMPICS COME.
WHAT WILL BE THE?
THE UNDERLYING AND.
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY OF SEX
TRAFFICKING AS WELL WHICH WE
KNOW IS IS A BIG ISSUE IN LOS
ANGELES I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SUMMARY MIKLOS.
I THINK THAT WHAT THIS IS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR KNIFE AT.
OKAY WE NEED A SECOND.
OKAY.
OF THE QUESTION.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY AYE AYE LACKEY I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CONCISELY JR.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK NO QUIRK KNOW
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
MEASURE PASSES.
SO MEMBER TING.
MAYBE TWENTY OR THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY A.
STRIVES TO STREAMLINE OUR
CURRENT EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS.
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS.
WE KNOW THAT. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME BY SERVE
PROBATION.
HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS THERE
THEY HAVE A TEN PERCENT INCREASE
IN EMPLOYMENT RATE ONCE. OUR
RECORDS HAVE BEEN EXPUNGED ARE
CURRENTLY ARE EXPLAINED REPRISE
THIS IS.
THE ARE RATHER ONEROUS IT'S A
LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED.
AND WE HAVEA BACKLOG WHAT WE
HOPE TO DO IS TO STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS MOVING FORWARD WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS.
REGARDING THE FISCAL COST FOR
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY. SO WE WILL BE
REMOVING THAT ARE RETROACTIVE
NATURE OF FROM THE LEGISLATION.
IN JUST MOVING AHEAD AND LOOKING
AT THIS PRO ACTIVELY.
WE ALSO ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THEIR PARTICULAR
CONCERNS. ABOUT WHETHER SHE
SHOULD COUNSEL PROBATION OR THE
TRIBUTARIES WITH THE CONTINUING.
TO OUR WORK WITH THEM AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. COME.
AS YOU ALL KNOW IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE SPEND ABOUT
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
BUDGET.
ONE OF THE BIG HURDLES
FOR AND THE BIG EXPENSES ARE
THEIR CAN THE REAP REPEAT
OFFENDER SO WHERE THE MAIN
REASONS WE HAVE REPEAL. PEOPLE
CANNOT GET EMPLOYMENT I. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROCESS PROGRESS OVER THE LAST
NUMBER YEARS. TO. HELP PEOPLE
ONCE THEY'VE.
SERVE THEIR CRIME AND SERVE
THEIR TIME.
REALLY HAVE THOSE RECORDS CLEAR.
AND THIS REALLY IS THAT PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD ON.
THE RECORDS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES WILL REMAIN SO IF YOU
ARE AT PEACE OFFICER YOU'RE A
JUDGE YOU'RE A PROBATION OFFICER
JUST PRETENDING YOU WILL
CONTINUE DEAL TO SEE. THOSE
RECORDS IN YOUR DATABASE THIS
IS.
A BUT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
TRYING TO HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
GET EMPLOYMENT ONCE THEY HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME.
NOT WITHOUT A HAPPY TO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES.
ANDRE PERRY FROM CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
AND.
HE ONLY SEES HERNANDEZ FROM THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
HI GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
TANG IN YOUR CENTER FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE SPELLING THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
ALREADY STATED MOVING FORWARD WE
ARE.
.
REMOVING. THE RETROACTIVE PEACE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THIS BILL
WILL START FROM.
THE DAY AT ITS SIDE MOVING
FORWARD.
AS WE KNOW THE ISSUE AND COULD
BEING CONSIDERED TODAY IS NOT
ONLY A CONSEQUENTIAL STEP
TOWARDS OUR COLLECTIVE GOAL OF
ENSURING. THAT COMMUNITIES
THRIVE BUT IT'S ALSO FUNDAMENTAL
TO ERADICATE THE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL HAS
PERFORMED AT PERFORM THEIR DEBT
TO SOCIETY I WILL AND CUT MY
TIME SHORT IN ORDER TO GIVE OUR
TIME FOR.
HI GOOD MORNING.
.
HONORABLE JONES SAWYER IS NOT
HERE AND ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ONLY SAYS THAT NONE THIS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN LOCAL AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATING FOR DRUG
POLICIES CREDITED SCIENCE
HEALTH.
AND HUMAN RIGHTS THE REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS I'VE ORGANIZED
AND EXECUTED OVER FOUR DOZEN
EXPUNGEMENT FAIRS AND HVE
HELPED THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
OBTAIN EXPUNGEMENT. AND OTHER
FORMS OF POST CONVICTION RELIEF
THE CURRENT EXPOSURE PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA IS DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE EXPENSIVE TIME
CONSUMING AND ARDUOUS IT
REQUIRES A PETITIONER TO BE
FAMILIAR WITH DOZENS OF LEGAL
FORMS. OF FEE WAIVERS AND CORE
PROCESS HE'S MAKING IT
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT IF THEY
HAVE MULTIPLE CONVICTIONS IN
VARIOUS COUNTIES AND IN VARIOUS
COURT HOUSES.
EACH EXPUNGEMENT.
.
ALSO NEEDS TO BE SUBMITTED AT
THE COURTHOUSE THEY WERE
CONVICTED SO THAT'S ALSO VERY
TROUBLESOME. IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE THE X. BUT
REPETITION IS EIGHT PAGES LONG
YOU NEED TO MAKE FIVE COPIES AND
SUBMITTED TO FIVE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. AND LA COUNTY THE
EXPOSURE PETITION CAN BE UP TO
TWELVE PAGES LONG WITH EACH
COURTHOUSE REQUIRING DIFFERENT
FORMS AND WAIVERS. ANYTHING CAN
LEAD TO A REJECTION EVEN NOT
HOLE PUNCHING THE DOCUMENTS
CORRECTLY.
THERE'S A HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
FILING FEE FOR EVERY EXPERT
REPETITION FILED THIS YOU CAN
STACK UP IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
CONVICTIONS CAUSING BARRIERS FOR
PEOPLE WHO. ARE LOW INCOME OR
CAN'T GET JOBS OR EVEN IN SOME
COUNTIES WHERE THE FEE CANNOT BE
WAIVED.
IN SHORT THERE IS NO UNIFORM
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA THAT CAN BE
EASILY OR SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATED
BY REGULAR PERSON EVEN SOMEONE
LIKE MYSELF WAS YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS.
.
THERE ARE FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED STICK RESTRICTIONS THAT.
EXIST FOR SOMEONE HAS A
CRIMINAL RECORD OF THESE
RESTRICTIONS FIFTY PERCENT ARE
EMPLOYMENT RELATED AND SEVENTY
THREE PERCENT ARE PERMITTED
BANDS.
A MANY OF THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE
REMOVED AND THE INDIVIDUAL GETS
ON X. OF THE CONVICTION EXPUNGED
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
ALLOWS FOR MORE CALIFORNIANS TO
OBTAIN RELIEF. OPENING THE DOORS
ARE TO HOUSING EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. I KNOW
COMMUNITY WINS WHEN THERE ARE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO CAN'T GET
A JOB OR HOUSING.
ONCE AGAIN I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT A BILL THAT WILL HELP OUR
COMMITTEE'S DRIVE BY REMOVING
THE BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY.
THANK YOU AND.
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S JAIL AMERICAN I'M WITH
THE EAST BAY TWENTY LAW CENTER
AS MY COLLEAGUES HERE ALREADY
STATED THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR A LOT OF REASONS EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S CRITICAL ON THE GROUND AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
WHERE I WORK BUT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT FOLKS THERE'S
SUCH A BACKLOG THAT YOU CAN
APPLY FOR AN EXPUNGEMENT IN
JANUARY AND NOT ACTUALLY GET A
COURT DATE UNTIL SEPTEMBER? KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF YOU HAVE
EMPLOYMENT ISSUES IF YOU HAVE
IMMIGRATION ISSUES IF YOU HAVE
HOUSING ISSUES THAT COME UP IN
THE EANTIME.
THEN YOU'RE JUST YOU JUST LOSE
OUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT FOLKS ARE
FACING AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID IN
OTHER COUNTIES IT'S EVEN WORSE
IN OTHER COUNTIES THERE MAY BE A
SITUATION THERE'S NOT
ORGANIZATION LIKE DB CLC AND YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT ON YOUR
OWN YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT ALL
THIS LEGAL LANGUAGE. ON YOUR OWN
SO I THINK.
I THINK ASSEMBLY RETAINING FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS I THINK
AND I REALLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
HI.
MY NAME IS THE INHERENT I'M
REPRESENTING A CHECKER A
CONSUMER REPORTING AGENCY IN
NATIONALLY CREDIT BACKGROUND
SKINNER.
I'M HERE TODAY.
REPRESENTING CHECKER.
BECAUSE THIS BILL IS UP MORE
THAN ABOUT THE AYE EXPUNGEMENT
BUT.
MORE SO ABOUT EMPLOYMENT SO.
CHECKER DO YOU SOME CONTEXT HAS
RUN ABOUT SIXTEEN MILLION
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN LAS FOR
YEARS.
TWENTY BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WHAT COMES OUT OF THAT IS NOT
CHEST UP PUBLIC RECORD BUT ALSO
THE DECISIONS THAT EMPLOYERS
MAKE SO I'M HAVING A CRIMINAL
RECORD?
JUST IN GENERAL CUTS APPLICANTS
JOB CHANCES BATES CLEAN HOUSE BY
FIFTY PERCENT.
.
BY.
EXPANDING DOT THE KIND A PATHWAY
TO GET EXPUNGEMENT.
WERE SEEING NOW PLAYERS HOP ON.
THE WAGON HERE TO ACTUALLY LOOK
FOR MORE LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR WORKERS IT
SAT A TIGHT JOB MARKET RIGHT NOW
AND.
COMPANIES ARE GROWING IT'S A
GOOD TIME FOR THE ECONOMY SO
YOUR TRADITIONAL KIND OF AB KIM
PULLS.
ARE NOT AVAILABLE LIKE THEY
WERE A FEW YEARS AGO SO.
WERE LOOKING FOR.
EMPLOYERS LOOKING FOR MORE
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY COME TO THE
TABLE AND ARE LOOKING TO GIVE
FAIR CHANCES BUT.
BEING AFFAIR.
BEING A BACKGROUND SCREENER WE
ARE ARE REGULATED BY THE FAIR
CREDIT REPORTING ACT.
IN WITH THAT WE HAVE A.
.
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
MAXIMUM POSSIBLE ACCURACY.
THAT INCLUDES EXPUNGEMENT AND
THE ACTUAL.
ACCURACY OF SOMEBODY'S
EXPUNGEMENT STATUS SO.
IF SOMEBODY HOUSING EXPUNGEMENT
REPORTING AGENCIES LIKE
OURSELVES.
WHICH ALL EMPLOYERS ARE USING
FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS WILL NOT
REPORT THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT'S GIVING PEOPLE.
A BETTER HEADWAY FOR A JOB
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN ESSENCE ARE
BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE CRIMINAL
RECORDS.
SO BY.
HAVING BETTER PATHWAYS TO
EXPUNGEMENT WE ARE AYE GIVING
PEOPLE MORE.
AVAILABILITY TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY.
ORDERS COMMITTED VOTES.
AYE ON THIS THANK YOU.
GIVE TAKE YOU A OTHER WITNESSES
AND SPORT.
KATHY SHARE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DRESS LIKE OUT IT UP WITH THE
ALLIANCE WAS MEN OF COLOR
SUPPORT.
ERIC ANDERSON WITH ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN MANY HYATT IN
SUPPORT.
AND I CHAU CRIMES REYES FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
TO ANYONE WITH A SENIOR UN
SUPPORT.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE I MY NAME IS DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE ARCHIE
PROBATION OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
FIRST I WANT TO THANK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM IN AND HIS OFFICE ON
AND THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH.
SEE PARK ON THIS ISSUE WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE I'M CERTAINLY
SHARE THE INTENSE WE ARE STRONG
PROPONENTS OF REMOVING BARRIERS
I'M TO RE ENTRY TO.
YOU KNOW WANTING TO FACILITATE
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT ALL OF THOSE
SERVICES SO I THINK WE COME FROM
A. AYE AYE SHARED MISSION ON IN
THAT REGARD.
FOR APPROPRIATION AS WE LOOK AT
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL RIGHT NOW
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
REMOVAL OF THE RETROACTIVITY
PIECE. ON THAT THAT ADDED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT I THINK.
FROM THE WORKLOAD PERSPECTIVE
OPERATION CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
PERSONS UNDER OUR SUPERVISION
AND SO WE AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE AUTO EXPUNGEMENT.
FOR THAT POPULATION THERE'S
MANY QUESTIONS THAT ARISE ABOUT.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT IN THAT
CASE WHERE SOMEBODY WHICH WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE BUT
WERE SOME HE DOES COME BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM?
HOW MANY TIMES ARE THEY
ELIGIBLE FOR ON THIS RELIEF WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE WE WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH THE COURT'S PERMISSION IN
THE ENTIRE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION WE
NEED TO BEST SERVE THEM?
WHEN THEY COME BACK IF THEY DO
COME BACK INTO THE SYSTEM.
SO THERE CERTAINLY FISCAL COSTS
I THINK.
FOR PERMISSION WE STILL BELIEVE
THERE'S A.
A VERY STRONG NEED FOR THE
COURT TO HAVE A ROLE IN THIS.
IN THIS PROCESS AND IN LOOKING
AT THESE PETITIONS SO I'M WERE
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON
HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT.
EXISTING LAW PRESENTLY HOW THE
PROCESS BY WHICH A PERSON CAN
WITH MINIMAL EFFORT OBTAIN THIS
RELIEF.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
ELIMINATES OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PROSECUTING AGENCY TO CHALLENGE
THE RELIEF. IF THEY BELIEVE THE
PERSON DOES NOT QUALIFY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF
ANOTHER OFFENSE
OR FACING CURRENT CHARGES.
ALL OF THESE CHANGES RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND WORKLOAD
FOR A TRIAL COURT'S LIKELY AT
THE EXPENSE OF THEIR CURRENT
TASKS IN OBLIGATIONS. WHICH TEND
TO BE MORE PUBLIC SAFETY RELATED
RATHER THAN CLEANING UP OLD
RECORDS.
WE BELIEVE THE EXISTING PROCESS
OFFICIALLY BALANCES A PERSON'S
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK RELIEF.
BUT THE PROSECUTION'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
ONLY QUALIFYING OFFENDERS ARE
ABLE TO BENEFIT.
WE'RE ABLE TO DO THIS WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES AND SEE NO
REASON WHY THE PROCESS NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED.
SHARON RILEY.
ON BEHALF OF JUDICIAL COUNCIL
VERY BRIEFLY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S.
AMENDMENTS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
PRACTICAL.
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE COURTS
WILL GET ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
IN ORDER TO VERIFY THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IS ELIGIBLE FOR
EXPUNGEMENT AND FOR EXAMPLE ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS.
WOULD BE DETERMINING WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL HUSTLER LIVED IN
HONEST AND UPRIGHT LIFE.
AND ALSO I'M COURTS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE.
THE RAP SHEETS AND THEY WOULD
ORDINARILY GET THAT INFORMATION
FROM THE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
SO AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOKING AT WORKING WITH AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSOR IN THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. ON ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WORLD.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IN.
SEEING NONE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER KILEY.
BAG MORNING THAT MISTER TING AND
SO I THINK THERE'S A.
A LOT BEHIND THIS THAT I I CAN.
SUPPORT IN PRINCIPLE AND I I
WILL NOTE THE SORT OF DIE IN
INCONGRUITY THAT.
THIS BILL WILL NOT A FACT I THE
QUALIFICATION OF SOMEONE.
WHO HAS A CONVICTION FOR AN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE THAT IS?
THAT IS.
GIVEN BY.
BY STATE THE STATE OR STATE
AGENCIES.
AND IN FACT US SUCH PEOPLE WILL
STILL NOT BE AYE QUALIFIED EVEN
GET A LICENSE IN MANY CASES.
SO I THINK THERE'S SOME.
INCONGRUITY. IN THAT THE VERY
THING THE IDEA THAT IS A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION.
THAT DISQUALIFIES YOU.
FROM BEING LICENSED BY THE
STATE I'M THIS BILL IS KIND OF
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO AYE
CONCEAL FROM EVEN BEING A FACTOR
IN THE DECISION A PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS AND SO. I'M ACTUALLY
AYE TAKING ON.
MEASURE TO.
ADDRESS THE FIRST PART AND I
INVITE YOU TO WORK WITH ME ON
THAT AND WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
AS A CO AUTHOR OF.
AND THAT YOU KNOW I IF IT'S
TRUE THAT IT'S TAKING A LONG
TIME FOR PEOPLE TO GET THE SORT
OF RELIEF THE BACKLOG OF ONE OF
THE WITNESSES. I'VE TALKED
ABOUT.
I THINK THAT'S BAD AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
AND I COULD CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW. THE MAGIC SUPPORTING
THE MORE STREAMLINED PROCEDURE
BUT I THIS IS FOR THE REASONS
THAT BEEN CITED HERE IN
OPPOSITION SIMPLY I MAKING THE
SOMETHING AUTOMATIC I DON'T
THINK IS IS IN THE INTERESTS OF
OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT. I THINK IS
REALLY WORKABLE.
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT INTENDS
BEHIND IT.
ANY OTHER. YES. CARILLO THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION BOTH AND
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. I JUST A
QUESTION ON THE AND THE REMOVAL
OF THE AUTOMATIC EXPUNGEMENT.
SO DOES THAT MEAN THAT.
FOLKS THAT WERE ON PROBATION
AFTER NINETEEN SEVENTY WILL
STILL BE ABLE TO APPLY.
YES DAHLE WILL GO THROUGH THAT
APPLICATION PROCESS.
WE JEWS WOULDN'T ALLOW THEM THE
AUTO EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS AND
PART OF THAT IS. BASED ON OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH PROBATION
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ON THEY FOUND THAT
PROCESS RATHER ONEROUS AND THE
WORKLOAD FAIRLY FAIRLY SIZEABLE
SO. WE REALLY FELT THAT HOME
BASED ON BASED ON THAT SITUATION
WE WANTED TO DO IT MOVING FOR
START AGAIN JANUARY FIRST WHEN
THE BILL WOULD BECOME ACTIVE
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION.
YES MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
IRONMAN.
STILL NOT SURE.
I I THINK THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT
I MEAN I I WAS OUT A NO I
UNDERSTAND THERE WERE
NEGOTIATIONS THE RECOMMENDATION
WILL NOW BE A YES.
.
I'M CONCERNED BUT I DON'T KNOW I
I DON'T FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN A
FAX HAVE ASK FOR.
SPECIFICALLY A LIST OF. OF THE
THE CRIMES THAT ARE
AUTOMATICALLY EXPUNGED.
I.
THAT ALWAYS CONCERNS ME BECAUSE
I HAVE VOTED IN THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE ON THINGS AND THEN LATER
FOUND OUT ON THE WERE CERTAIN
CRIMES ON THEIR THAT. I WOULDN'T
BE COMFORTABLE WITH AN AUTOMATIC
EXPUNGEMENT FOR.
IN SO I'M NOT SURE WHEN OR HOW
I CAN GET THAT LIST.
I A I A.
INSISTS THAT ON THE ONE HAND
FROM ESPECIALLY APPROPRIATIONS
STANDPOINT WHICH ARE NOT
CONSIDERING HERE THE THE REMOVAL
OF THE NINETEEN SEVENTY.
KIND OF ARBITRARY DATE IS A
POSITIVE ONE BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND.
I THINK ABOUT KIND OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND HOW
FAR WE'VE COME AND.
HOW MUCH MORE FAIR IT IS TODAY
THAN IT HAD BEEN ESPECIALLY
THROUGH THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND SO I'M CONCERNED THAT I
MIGHT HAVE IT CREATING KIND OF A
TWO CLASS SOCIETY THAT ARE?
EXASPERATING WHAT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM A A TWO CLASS SOCIETY
JUST LOOK AT THE WAY WE DEAL
WITH DRUGS TODAY COMPARED TO.
YOU KNOW THE CRACK EPIDEMIC IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES.
SO.
I'M CA AYE AYE.
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT
APPRECIATE THIS CHANGE BUT FROM
A.
A EQUITABLE FAIRNESS STANDPOINT
THINK THAT THEY'RE AT THAT.
.
I CONCERNED. I'M.
OF THOSE ANSWERS.
.
ANSWERED I THINK I'M GONNA HAVE
TO LAY OFF TODAY I'M REALLY
PSYCHED THAT WANT TO GET THERE I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
IS WRITE MY THING YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY HAVE DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN POST CONVICTION RELIEF
IN ALL OF THESE THINGS. IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND YET I JUST
HAVE TOO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
IN A SITUATION WHERE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND I'M MAKING
POLICY DECISIONS.
AND THEN WE'RE COMING BACK HERE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IN THE PAST
AND SO.
WE WILL I I JUST WANNA GET IT
RIGHT AND SO I'M THE LAYOFF OF
AT THIS TIME I'D LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE
AND. I'M GETTING TO A POINT OF
FEELING MORE COMFORTABLE ABOUT
THIS BILL BEFORE I CAN SUPPORT
IT I'M AND I HOPE THAT IT MOVES
FORWARD I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
RICK IN IT COULD DISMISS AYE
TORT CROSS WHAT QUICK ISSUE SO
I'M HAPPY TO GET TO THE I THINK
WE DO HAVE A LIST.
MY STAFF CAN.
PROVIDE THAT SO JUST JUST TO
CLARIFY THIS BILL DOES NOT
EXPAND OR CONTRACT THE CURRENT
THE CURRENT.
CRIMES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
EXPUNGEMENT IT JUST STREAMLINED
THAT PROCESS.
SURE BUT IT MAKES AN AUTOMATIC
CORCORAN WHICH.
LEAVES JUDGMENT OUT
CRACKED.
WHOA WHOA.
THANK YOU POLITE.
LET I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT
WORKS NOW YEAH THANK YOU TEAR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO SO THE BASE
IS BEHIND THIS A LEGISLATION IS
ARM TO WHAT THREE POINT FOUR
WHICH IS EXPUNGEMENT RIGHT IT'S.
REMOVAL OF PLEA.
IT SAYS STATES IN STATUE THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE MANDATED
EXPUNGEMENT BUT THIS BILL IT
WILL NOT TAKE.
I'M DISCRETION AWAY FROM THE
DATE THE DETERMINES OFFICE ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO STOP
EXPUNGEMENT. THEY'VE THEY WITH
TWO OF THE THIRTY DAYS TO STOP
NEXT MONTH IF THEY WANT TO DO IT
EXPEDITED PROCESS AND TAKES THE
ONUS. OFF OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WERE POURING CANNOT YOU KNOW.
GO TO TRAVEL TO FOUR DIFFERENT
COUNTIES IT JUST SAYS HEY
PROBATION WILL AUTUMN WALL
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS RIGHTS
WOULDN'T CHANGE ANY ANY CURRENT
LAW IT'S IT'S LITERALLY PUTS THE
ONUS ON PROBATION WHICH WHEN
THEY TERMINATE PRO PROBATION.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDING
EXPUNGEMENT IT'S PARTY IN
STATUTE ALREADY IT SAYS YOU KNOW
THAT.
PROBATIONER.
SALE GET THE RECORD EXPUNGED.
THROUGH A TO BECOME THE PROCESS
LIKE
TUCKER.
TESTIFIED EARLIER AND EBSCO SEE
IN DPA AND ALL OF OF TO OPPOSE
EXPERT RELIEF REALIZE THAT
PEOPLE ONE EXPUNGEMENT BUT IT
JUST SOUL SO HARD SO IF IN
STATUTE THERE ALREADY MANDATE
THE GIVEN EXPUNGEMENT WHY NOT
HAVE THAT PROCESS EXPEDITED.
THROUGH.
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT WHICH
WHICH WHICH.
WHICH IS MANDATED BY STATUTE
ALREADY AND DO NOT TAKE ANYTHING
AWAY FROM THE DA'S OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO STOP EXPUNGEMENT.
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I'M.
THERE IS ONE THING THAT
CONCERNED ME IT RELIEVES A LOT
OF MY CONCERNS ON A POLICY
STANDPOINT.
THAT IN ACTUALLY I'M.
GETS ME CLOSER THERE THINK
CONCERNED PACEY SAID HE PUTS THE
ONEROUS ON PROBATION.
WELL WORK ORGANIZA.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S THE
PROCESS WHICH WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS A VERY IS A PROCESS IN WHICH.
YOU KNOW IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE
THEN IT MAKES IT A LOT EASIER
AND SO ON THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION IS TO LOOK AT A
PROCESS THAT COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY. RIGHT TO CHORDS THE
PURSUING YOU KNOW EVERYBODY A
LOT OF MONEY AND MAKE THAT
PROCESS LESS MONEY.
MAKE THE THE PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT AND THEN MAKE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA WAS LIKE SO THE
THIRTY DAY.
CHALLENGE PORTION DOES THAT.
DOES THAT.
IS THAT THIRTY DAYS RIGHT AFTER
A PERSON IS FINISHED PROBATION
OR WHEN THEY APPLY FOR
EXPUNGEMENT.
WHEN I APPLY FOR ITS BUDGET.
ONCE A PIE FOR EXPUNGEMENT.
SO I AM SORRY I JUST HAVE NO
IDEA HOW THIS WORKS AT THAT
WOULD I ACTUALLY THOUGHT WAS
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
.
SO.
HOW IS THAT IS SO?
WHEN YOU SAY IT'S PRIMER
ONEROUS.
ON PROBATION.
POWELL Y..
COR FOR THE QUESTION WILL YOU
SAID THIS TAKES AWAY THE OWNERS
OF THE CRIMINAL.
I'M I DON'T USE THE WORD
CRIMINAL THAT YOU ARE THAT I WAS
LIKE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE. DEFEND AND THE PLEA YOUR
LOVE.
THE PERSON IN THE COURT SYSTEM
AND PUTS IT. MORE PUT MORE
ONEROUS ON BUT THERE'S MORE
OWNERS PLAYED A PROBATION NOT ON
PROBATION LIKE ON THE PROCESS
SO IT ON THE PROCESS NOT ON
PROBATION OFFICERS NO ADDITIONAL
STEP ON THE PROCESS THERE YOU
GO.
I MISSPOKE YOU YOU GUYS REALLY
GOT TO GET IN EXPLAINS BILLS TO
ME BEFORE RECENTLY AND. AND I
MEAN SERIOUSLY THIS IS A REALLY
COMPLICATED AND I'M I'M I WANT
TO GET THERE AND FOR SOMEBODY
LIKE ME TO COME IN AND BE VERY
CLEAR THAT. I DON'T THINK I'M
THERE THAT LIKE HEY THAT SHOULD
BE A RED FLAG THAT IT'S NOT
REALLY CLEAR WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE SO.
AND YET IMAGINE IF YOU ARE NOT
CLEAR NOW PERSON WHO DIDN'T
EXPLODE WITH RELIEVING CLOUT IN
JUST MATTER IF I'M NOT UNCLEAR
THERE TO ME LIVE OTHER
LEGISLATORS WHO PROBABLY AREN'T
IN THE SAME MENTAL SPACE THAT
ARE SO ALRIGHT. SO.
WITH THAT I THINK ALL OF
SANTIAGO WITH IT IS THAT YOU
COULD CAN I FINISH I'M SORRY.
TO SHARE.
I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY I'M ON
THE CONDITION OF EVERYTHING
YOU'RE TOLD ME IS TRUE WHAT YOU
MEAN BY OPENNESS AND
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE BUT I DO
AGREE THAT THERE IS A SYSTEM
THAT IS BACKLOGGED. THERE IS IF
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND IT HERE ARE
YOU KNOW ASK LEGISLATORS I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR
EVERYDAY PEOPLE TRYING TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS ESPECIALLY.
IF THEY ARE INVOLVED IN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT STEPS ACROSS OUR
STATE.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO
OUR ATTENTION.
SANTIAGO DOMESTIC WORK.
SURE AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR FOR HIS HARD WORK
JUST MAKE IT MAYBE ECHOA COUPLE
THINGS IF IF I MAY. UM.
BECAUSE IT DID GIVE ME A LITTLE
BIT OF HEARTBURN IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT PLACES RIGHT AND I'M.
I WON'T ECHO TOO MUCH ON THE TWO
TIER SYSTEM BY THINK I THINK AT
SOME POINT AND NEED THAT DOES
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
AND CERTAINLY WE WANT TO GIVE
PEOPLE A SECOND OPPORTUNITY.
STRUGGLE LITTLE INTERNALLY WITH
THE PERSON WHO WHO ON THEIR OWN.
WANTS TO CHANGE THEIR LIFE AND
TAKE SOME SORT OF INITIATIVE.
TO CHANGE OUR LIFE AND GOES TO
THE EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS AS
OPPOSED TO LET'S JUST SIX BUNGE
EVERYBODY EVEN THOSE WHO ARE NOT
LESS FEELING SOME SORT OF CHANGE
OR REMORSE OR. WANTING TO GET
THEIR LIFE ARE ON TRACK EVEN
THOUGH I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
INTENT IS.
ALSO STRUGGLE FROM TIME TO IT
HEARING THIS.
KIND OF LIKE SOME ALLOWS WE
PASSED IT IN THE PAST RIGHT SO
IF A USED TO BE A FELONY DE TO
STEAL SOMETHING. AT A CERTAIN
NUMBER NINE FIFTY IN OFFICE AND
IT'S A MISDEMEANOR.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO YOU THERE
SOME WHO ALLEGE THAT WE'VE
CREATED A SYSTEM NOW WHERE
PEOPLE WILL GO TO THIS RIGHT
UNDER.
AND NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS BECAUSE IT'S NOW A
MISDEMEANOR FREE PASS AYE ONE
WANT TO CREATE THROUGH THIS. A
PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE SAY WHY GO
DO IT'S GONNA GET EXPLAINS
ANYWAYS.
AND NOW IT'S LIKE HATE THOSE
METAL WE DO IT'S EXPUNGED.
AND SO JUST TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION I THINK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT IS
FAIR FOR PEOPLE.
AND CERTAINLY.
THAT REWARDS THE THE INCENTIVE
INSIDE OF A PERSON THAT SAYS HEY
I WANT CHANGE AND I WANNA GO GET
A JOB I WANT TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE. AMOUNTS ARE SURE THAT I
FEEL COMFORTABLE ON.
BUT I KNOW I MAY REGRET Y. SE
BUT WANTING TO HELP THOSE WHO
DON'T WANT TO CHANGE OUR LIFE I
DON'T WANT TO HELP.
AND I'D RATHER FOCUS MY
RESOURCES ON THOSE WHO WANT TO
DO SOMETHING WITH OUR LIVES.
AS MR COURT. ARM.
THE FIRST THING THEY SAY IS.
WHAT FIRST OF ALL OF THE WITNESS
NEXT YOU MISTER TANG COULD YOU?
?
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT. DAY JORDAN
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. ARE.THINK
VERY IMPORTANT WE ADVANCE THIS
BILL TODAY.
MISTER CHANG IS. AN EXEMPLARY A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE I KNOW
THAT HE WILL BE WORKING WITH
EVERYONE TO MAKE SURE IT IS
FAIR.
I ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT IF YOU
HAVE MET THE PEOPLE. ARE UGLY
WAS AFTER PROP FORTY SEVEN THERE
WERE A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
WHO.
.
WERE SUDDENLY ELIGIBLE FOR
EXPUNGEMENT.
IT LETS A DIFFICULT PROCESS
AND OU'VE GOT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO COMMIT THESE
CRIMES TYPICALLY HAVE VERY
COMPLICATED LIVES.
AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE AS MUCH
EDUCATION AS THE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM HERE.
AND AS A RESULT.
AND EIGHTEEN PAGE.
A PAPER IS VERY HARD TO DEAL
WITH OR THE FACT THAT ONE PERSON
YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT COURTS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
EXPUNGEMENT STUDIO. AND THE.
.
THE RESULTS CAN DIFFER COURT TO
COURT. I THINK THIS IS IN THE
CENTRAL BAIL.
.
BECAUSE WHAT WE REALLY WANT.
IS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE A
MISTAKE IN THE PAST TO BE ABLE
TO GO FORWARD.
AND THEY CAN'T GO FORWARD IN TO
WORK LEGALLY IF THEY'RE
PREVENTED FROM GETTING THAT WORK
BY HAVING SOMETHING ON THEIR
RECORD.
SO I THINK IN TERMS OF MAKING
THE BEST MOVE FORWARD.
HAVE A SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE CAN
MAKE A LIVING.
FARM THINGS OTHER THAN CRIME
THIS WOULD BE A MAJOR STEP
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHANG.
AND.
NO IF NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
MISTER TING YOU MAKE LOVE THEY
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF REALLY
JUST THINK MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR QUESTIONS.
THIS IS A IS A PROCESS BILL AS
YOU COULD TELL IT'S TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS THAT IS.
I AT THIS POINT NOT VERY USER
FRIENDLY. A WE HAVE STE.
THREE MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS IN
THAT PROCESS THAT WE ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY TO SO THAT. THEY
CAN BE PART OF THAT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS.
ON IT AND SO I'VE I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS I THINK
YOU ALL UNDERSTAND HOW
DIFFICULT.
AND COMPLICATED THIS PROCESSES.
AND AGAIN JUST A ECHO ON THEIR
WITNESSES POINT THAT THIS IS
EVEN MORE CHALLENGING IF YOU'RE
THE ONE AT THE BEGINNING OF THAT
TRYING. PROCESS TRYING TO GET TO
THE TOP. SO AGAIN HERE WE WILL
ACTUALLY BE WORKING TO A FIND A
WAY TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT
PROBATION JUDICIAL COUNCIL DISK
TWENTIES WILL HAVE THEIR ABILITY
TO HAVE INPUT. WE ALSO DON'T
WANT TO NOTSTREAMLINED THE
PROCESS BECAUSE THERE'S A FEW
EXCEPTIONS WHICH WHICH IS WHAT
REALLY HAPPENS ARE A FEW
EXCEPTIONS. THAT GET PULLED OUT
OF THE MANDATORY IT EXPUNGEMENT
PROCESS BUT WE DON'T WANT TO LET
EVERYBODY ELSE SIT THERE IN
PURGATORY BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO AGAIN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
QUESTIONS WILL CONTINUE TO.
WORK ON THIS AND AND I THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
MORE.
MORE REFINED BILL HOPEFULLY BY
THE TIME IT IT IT CAN REACH THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU.
WITHOUT RESPECT US FOR ABOUT A
DAY AND END UP AND I WOULD THANK
YOU MISTER KING FOR.
YOU KNOW LISTENING TO MY
CONCERNS BUT AND.
AND WHAT UNTIL I REALIZED.
JUST RECENTLY THAT THAT YOU
KNOW.
POSSIBLY CHAIR OF BUDGET IN A
CHAIR OF APPROACH.
MIGHT BE.
FAVORABLE TO ACTUALLY HELPING
TO FUND IT BEFORE SEVENTY NINE
WHICH I DIDN'T. THINK WOULD BE
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE.
SO I'M GLAD SHE PULLED IT BACK
BUT WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT. LOOK
AT PEOPLE BEFOREHAND IF WE WANT
TO DO THAT. M. WHATEVER THAT
EXPENSES WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
TO TO DO THAT AND AND TO PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND THE
NET THE INTO TODAY. IF WE WANT
TO HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN.
PROSECUTED FOR CRIMES THAT ARE
NOW LEGAL.
WELL THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THAT I WOULD ALSO.
TAKE DIRECT MEDICATIONS OF OF OF
THE MEMBERS HERE.
WHO SAID COME TO OUR OFFICE AND
EXPLAIN I FOR EXAMPLE SHARE?
PUBLIC SAFETY I'VE HAD.
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUALS COME TO
ME AND TELL ME HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS.
I GET AN EXPUNGEMENT.
AND I'VE HEARD FIRST HAND ALL
THE HORROR STORIES
AND I WOULD SUGGEST YOU BRING
THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTO THESE
OFFICES.
SO THEY CAN RELAY THEIR THEIR
DIRT. THERE DIFFICULTY TRYING TO
GET THROUGH THE REGULAR
EXPUNGEMENT PROCESS AND WHY YOU
EVEN.
TAKING THIS ON.
BECAUSE.
AS.
SOME MEMBERS ARE SAYING.
I JUST THINK ALL YOU NEED TO DO
IS FILL OUT A PREFAB NOT.
THE MEDIAN DATING JUST NEED
PHILIP PIECE OF PAPER AND IT'S
DONE.
AND IT'S
IT'S NOT THAT SIMPLE AND IN SOME
CASES IT MAY NOT EVEN BE FAIR
AND OR MAYBE SOME PERSONAL
PREJUDICES GOING ON EVEN IN
THAT.
AND WHICH I'VE HEARD AGAIN
BRINGING SOMEONE INTO TO EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND I
GUESS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS. WHAT IS DEPRIVE I HAPPEN TO
BE FAMILIAR WITH IT BECAUSE I'VE
HEARD SO MANY STORIES?
BUT I THEIR MEMBERS HERE I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS AND
THEN LASTLY I THINK YOU WILL.
WILL MAKE SURE WE DON'T BOMB.
WE DON'T END UP IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE KNOWINGLY.
.
CREATE A AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CRIMINALS TO ABUSES
OF. THAT AND I. I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GO ON
OUR WAY TO THINK OF THE WHAT
IFS.
CRIMINALS WILL BE CRIME AND YOU
TROUBLES GOING TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO GET AROUND. ANYTHING WE
DO. AND SO.
.
BUT WHEN WE CONSCIOUSLY KNOW
THAT THEY MIGHT. AND WE DON'T
PUT ANY SAFEGUARDS.
I THINK CLUB MEMBERS HERE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME SOMETHING IN
HERE THAT GIVES US SOME.
SOME OF FEELING OF CONFIDENCE
THAT THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
AND SO THE CHURCH RECOMMENDING
AND VOTE SO THAT WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND.
THE MOVE DISHONESTY MOVES TO. A
COMMITTEE THAT I THINK WILL BE
VERY GOOD AT.
HELPING YOU GET TO THAT NEXT
LEVEL.
THAT THAT I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ON AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NO CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SUBJECTS I.
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON. AB TWENTY FOUR
OH FIVE AND AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
OUT MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE.
OPPORTUNITY OF OF PRESENTING A.
B..
TWO FOUR ZERO FIVE.
.
THE BEGINNINGS OF OF.
THIS BILL.
.
WHICH REALLY WITHOUT.
THE AWAKENING OF THE OF THE OUR
OPIOID A CRISIS.
AND ALL OF THE INTER PLAYING.
REALITIES THAT ARE COMING DOWN.
AS A RESULT OF.
OPIOIDS WE KNOW ABOUT BUT ALSO
OPIOIDS THAT ARE. OFTEN TIMES.
HIDDEN OR OR CUTTING IN MIXED
WITH.
.
WITH OTHER DRUGS AND.
THERE THE CHARACTERISTICS OF
THESE PARTICULAR DRUGS.
SO.
A AB TWO FOUR OH FIVE ADDRESSES.
CAR FENTANYL.
IT IS AN OPIOID.
IT IS TEN THOUSAND TIMES MORE
POTENT THAN MORPHINE.
AT IT IS INTENDED USE IS AS A
SEDATIVE FOR ELEPHANTS.
IT ONLY TAKES A FEW GRANULES A
FEW GRANULES.
OF CAR FEDERAL THE SIZE OF
GRAINS OF TABLET SALT.
KILL SOMEONE.
HOWEVER THE DANGER OF THIS DRUG.
IS NOT REFLECTED IN OUR CURRENT
LAWS.
IN A COUPLE OF AREAS.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT I
THINK IS IT IS NOT A SCHEDULE
TWO DRUG.
SO AB TWO FOUR OH FIVE WILL ADD
CAR FEDERAL TO THE LIST.
SCHEDULED TO DRUGS.
IN ORDER TO HIGHLIGHT TO THE.
GROWING THREAT OF THIS
PARTICULAR.
A DRUG THAT IT THAT IT POSES.
BUT ALSO A IN ORDER TO CLEAR UP
THE AMBIGUITIES THAT UP RESULT
IN CAR FENTON ALL BEING IN SOME
IN SOME WAYS A. EITHER A
DERIVATIVE.
.
A OF.
ONE OF OF OFFEND ALL BUT. NOT
THAT THE THE BIGGER PROBLEM HERE
IS THAT IT IT IS IT IT LITERALLY
IS. A OFTENTIMES.
.
THE HIDDEN FROM.
THIS SCHEDULE TO.
PROSECUTION AND CONVICTION AND
SO BRINGING IT OUT OF THAT
UNCERTAINTY IN AMBIGUITY.
IS WHAT THE BILL DOES AS WELL IT
IT IS IMPORTANT.
TO KNOW WHAT THE BILL DOESN'T DO
WE DO NOT.
A PUNISH IN THIS BILL THE USER.
INSTEAD WE FOCUS.
ON STOPPING INDIVIDUALS.
M. HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE WITH
PENALTIES.
WHO WILLFULLY AND INTENTIONALLY
USE THE DRUG? AND SALAS.
THE IS AGAIN IT IS NOT THE USERS
THAT WE ARE GOING AFTER IT IS
THOSE WHO ARE.
CUTTING IT MIXING IT.
.
S. AND SELLING IT IN AND
TRANSPORTING IT FOR SALE.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
BUT WE WANT TO HAVE TO ELEVATE
THIS TO THIS KIND OF ATTENTION.
ISN'T IT IT IT IS SUCH A
TERRIBLE DRUG.
ARE.
DEADLY.
M. IT THE AMBIGUOUS WITH RESPECT
TO.
.
THOSE WHO SELL AND DISTRIBUTE
THAT.
A CAR FEDERAL THAT WE WANT TO.
MAKE THAT VERY VERY CLEAR IN THE
LAW.
AND HELP US UNDERSTAND THAT I'VE
OF WITH ME TODAY MISTER FLINT
ANDERSON. WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF
PARENTS AND ADDICTS IN NEED? AND
HE'S HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON A
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
YES I AM FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
PAIN PARENTS IN ATTICS IN NEED.
I AM ALSO A RECOVERING DRUG
ADDICT OF SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
SOBRIETY I HAD A TWENTY THREE
YEAR ADDICTION TO OPIATES.
AND YOU KNOW AGAIN WE AS YOU ALL
KNOW WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
OPIOID CRISIS THAT MAKES HIV
LOOK LIKE COLD AND FLU SEASON.
THIS IS THIS IS LITERALLY
KILLING LITERALLY KILLING.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
AND THE FACT THE MATTER IS IS
THAT CAR FENTON ALL NOW IS A
SYNTHETIC OPIOID THAT IS MAN
MADE. AND IT IS BEING SHIPPED
INTO OUR BORDERS ALONG THE
EASTERN SEABOARD AND AT SEA
BOARD AND THE AND THE AND THE
WEST COAST.
THE FACT THE MATTER IS IS THAT
THESE DRUGS ARE KILLING THESE
KIDS IT'S TASTELESS IT'S
ODORLESS.
NOBODY EVEN KNOWS THAT IT IS ON
THE DRUG THEY ARE LAY SEEN ST
NORCO WITH THAT ST VIKING AND
WHAT THAT ST LORD HAVE WITH
THAT.
THEY'RE LACING HEROIN WITH IT
AND NOT EVEN. TELLING.
THE END USER THAT THAT IT IS
LACED
WITH THIS.
AND JUST SO YOU DO NOW. I'D NOR
CAN IS INEFFECTIVE AGAINST CAR
FENTON ALL.
BY THE TIME YOU TAKE THIS AND
USED AS FIRST RESPONDERS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SAVE THEIR
LIVES WITH MARK AND.
THEY'RE LITERALLY DEAD BEFORE
THEY HIT THE GROUND.
THIS THIS THIS IS A CRISIS THAT
THAT HAS WE HAVE FORESEEN THIS
COMING FOR QUITE SOMETIME.
NOT ONLY IS THIS RUINING.
THE PERSON THAT IS USING THE
DRUG IT IS RUINING THEIR
FAMILIES AS WELL.
WE'VE SEEN OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
AND SENT OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE TO TREATMENT.
AND THESE ARE ALL IN THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS.
I BEEN TO NINETEEN FUNERALS.
IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS HALL
FROM OVERDOSE.
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE
KNOW OF.
WE KNOW WE ARE IN A BATTLE WE
ARE NO WE KNOW WE HAVE TO CHANGE
US AND WE HAVE TO FIX THIS
SOMEHOW SOME WAY.
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A LOT OF AFFECT
ON THOSE THAT ARE MANUFACTURING
THIS DRUG.
AND KILLING OUR CHILDREN WITH
IT.
THIS THIS IS THIS IS NO LONGER.
SOMEBODY ELSE'S PROBLEM.
THIS IS NO LONGER IT'S IT JUST
HAPPENS TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
THIS AFFECTS
ALL PEOPLE.
ALL RACES.
IT AFFECTS EVERYONE WHETHER
WHETHER WHETHER YOU LIVE ON ONE
SIDE OF TOWN OR THE OTHER.
WE WE HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE AND GET
AN OUR PROGRAMS THAT WERE THAT
WERE COLLEGE BASEBALL PLAYERS.
THAT STARTED OUT WITH THE
TYPICAL OPIOID FOR THEIR PAIN.
AND NOW BECAUSE THEY THEY THEY
THAT PAIN KILLER NO LONGER DOES
THE TRICK FOR THEM.
NOW THEY TURN TO STRONGER DRUGS
THEY TURN TO OXYCONTIN THE
CHURCH YOU HEROIN.
THIS IS THIS IS A FACT OF LIFE
THIS IS WHAT IS GOING ON ALL
ACROSS OUR STATE. AND OF COURSE
I ALWAYS GET ASKED
THE QUESTION ESPECIALLY BY
PARENTS.
CAN CAN AND AT THE CAN MARIJUANA
KILL YOU AND OF COURSE MY ANSWER
WAS ALWAYS NO.
TODAY IT'S A RESOUNDING YES.
BECAUSE DRUG DEALERS ALSO LACED
MARIJUANA.
WITH CAR FENTON ALL.
AND WHEN YOU CAN'T SMELL IT AND
YOU CAN'T TASTE IT AND YOU CAN'T
FEEL IT.
AND YOU INGEST IT.
IT IS A NINETY NINE POINT NINE
PERCENT CHANCE YOU'RE GOING TO
DIE ON THE SPOT.
WITH WITH WITHOUT HELP FROM
ANYBODY OR ANY OTHER DRUG TO
HELP YOU PULL YOURSELF OUT OF
IT.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I THANK MISTER
PATTERSON.
FOR HIM PRESENTING THIS TO YOU
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
NAME AND ORGANIZATION GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBER SEAN ON THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MAP IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IT'S PART.
AND BRIGHT ENOUGH ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN LEVEL ASSOCIATION OF.
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL POLICE OFFICERS ALL
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LUCIA MUCH ROBBIE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE VIET BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CRIME LAB DIRECTORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARI ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE GOING
BACK AS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE.
.
THE AUTHOR HAS IDENTIFIED A REAL
PROBLEM.
THE RATE OF DRUG OVERDOSE
RELATED TO OPIOIDS INCLUDING CAR
FENNEL AND FENNEL.
IS WIDESPREAD IN WORSENING.
HOWEVER THIS SOLUTIONS FOR THE
OVERDOSE CRISIS
PRIMARILY BE FOUND HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND HEALTH BUDGET.
IF THERE IN THIS COMMITTEE THEY
WILL NOT BE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING PENALTIES BY FOUR TO
FIFTEEN YEARS.
WE'VE HAD THE DRUG WAR FOR FORTY
YEARS
FOR FORTY YEARS WE'VE RESEARCH
THE EFFECTS OF LONG SENTENCES.
AND THE EFFECTS OF LONG
SENTENCES DID NOT REDUCE THE
AVAILABILITY OF DRUGS.
SURELY DO NOT REDUCE THE SPREAD
OF HIV AND. HEPATITIS AN
OVERDOSE RELATED TO DRUGS
DRUGS ARE STRONGER.
CHEAPER AND MORE AVAILABLE THAN
EVER BEFORE SO THIS TYPE OF
SOLUTION DIDN'T WORK AND SHOULD
NOT BE REPLICATED.
THE. RESEARCH IS ROBUST AND
FINDS THAT IT DOES NOT REDUCE
AVAILABILITY.
THAT YOU TAKE ONE DRUG.
SELLER OFFER THE STREET FOR A
SHORT PERIOD TIME OR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME THEY WILL REAP.
REPLACED BY ANOTHER DRUG SELLER
BECAUSE THIS IS A DEMAND MARKET.
THAT'S WHY DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
AND OUR ALLY SUPPORT.
PREVENTION TREATMENT CAN HARM
REDUCTION.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES PUBLISHED A
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR PAGE
REPORT.
ON THE AFFECT.
ON THE AFFECTS OF GET TOUGH
PENALTIES
WHAT IS THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCE
BASED ON THE AVAILABLE RESEARCH
OVER FORTY YEARS.
IT'S THE REDUCTION OF PENALTIES
REDUCTION OF THE PRISON
POPULATION AND SPENDING ARE
LIMITED GOVERNMENT MONEY ON
PREVENTION TREATMENT AND HARM
REDUCTION.
BY THE WAY AS I BELIEVE THE
AUTHORS ACKNOWLEDGE MUCH OF THE
ADDITION OF FENTANYL IN
CARBONDALE. TO THE.
TO DRUGS HAPPENS BEFORE IT
ENTERS THE.
ST BEFORE ENTERS THE NATION
HAPPENS
OUTSIDE OF THE U. S..
EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE POSSESSING
FOR SALE OR CAN TO SELL SMALL
AMOUNTS OF HEROIN MAY NOT KNOW
THAT THERE'S CAR FENELLA FENN
THOUGH IN THE PRODUCT SO THEY
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO EXTREMELY
HIGH PENALTIES. WITHOUT INTENT.
I WANT TO.
WRAP UP AND ALSO SAY THAT MY
COMMENTS WILL APPLY TO THE OTHER
BILL RELATED TO MASSIVE A
INCREASE IN PENALTIES SO I WILL
NOT. A OVER USE THE TIME OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM AND
WOULD WELCOME THE CHANCE TO WORK
WITH HIM AND OTHERS.
ON.
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
EVALUATEDTO WORK IN REDUCING
DEATH DISABILITY AND SUFFERING.
THANK YOU.
CATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA I WILL JUST JOIN
IN THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
AND SAY THAT WE KNOW THAT
INCREASED SENTENCES ARE NOT THE
ANSWER TO THE. EPIDEMIC OF
OPIOID ABUSE BUT INDEED DIVERT
RESOURCES THE FROM THE THINGS
THAT WORK LIKE TREATMENT AND
HARM REDUCTION AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER QUIRK
YEAH I'M FIRST OF ALL OF THE
WITNESS FOR THE BILL. AGE VERY
SERIOUS PLEASE NEVER SAY IT'S
LIKE CULT BUT DON'T SAY ANYTHING
PLEASE.
.
SECOND I AGREE VERY MUCH WITH
THE.
.
A TESTIMONY WITH MISTER GLENN
BACK HAS.
IT IS DEFINITELY THE CASE THAT
IF WE'RE GONNA SPEND MONEY WHAT
WE OUGHT TO SPEND IT ON THIS
TREATMENT.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A WAR ON
DRUGS WE HAD INCREASES IN
PENALTIES.
I DON'T THINK IT EVER DID ANY
GOOD.
PUTTING MORE PEOPLE IN PRISON IS
A LOT OF MONEY IT WOULD BE
BETTER SPENT IN OTHER WAYS THANK
YOU.
IT'S MUCH CARILLO.
I THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TORE ATTENTION I'LL ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER QUIRK WHO.
.
WELL LET ME LET ME SAY THIS AT
COST ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO INCARCERATE SOMEONE
IN PRISON AND LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS FOR LA COUNTY MY COUNTY
IT'S ABOUT FORTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY IN FACT ARE
COUNTY JAIL SYSTEMS ALREADY
OVERCROWDED. FOLKS I SHOULD BE
THERE BECAUSE THEY'RE WAITING
FOR BAIL OUR HELP LONGER.
OF PUTTING SOMEONE IN PRISON
COUNTY JAIL PUTTING SOMEONE IN
COUNTY JAIL FOR FIFTEEN YEARS IS
ALREADY.
LOOKING AT THE PROBLEM IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T FIND A SOLUTION IN
TERMS OF HOW DO WE GET DRUGS OFF
THE STREETS TO BEGIN WITH AND
SO.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO CONTINUE
TO INCARCERATE FOLKS.
WE KNOW DISPROPORTIONATELY THIS
IMPACTS PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO MEN
PREDOMINATELY.
AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
IN WHICH WE THINK ABOUT A
REHABILITATION. AND THINK ABOUT
BETTER SPEND TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE SO THAT THEY'RE NOT.
HAVE COMMITTING THESE CRIMES TO
BEGIN WITH AND I DO THINK THAT
IT IS AN EPIDEMIC I DO THINK
THAT WE HAVE. A REALLY SERIOUS
ISSUE ON OUR HANDS I'M NOT SURE
THAT INCARCERATING FOLKS FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS IS THE RIGHT
ANSWER TO THAT.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE PROVIDE
TO OUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
MR PASSION YOU MAKE CLOTHES I I
REALLY.
FIRST OF ALL BOB WANNA MAKE SURE
WE DON'T THAT.
CONFLATING CONNECT OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE.
A.
USERS ARE NOT A PART OF THIS
EFFORT.
ARE WE RECOGNIZE THAT USERS. ARE
IN MANY TIMES VICTIMIZED.
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH HERE IS
A HORRIBLE DRUG THAT IS
INCREASINGLY FINDING ITS WAY? UP
INTO THE THE THE VERY CARTELS IN
THE VERY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
CRIMINAL. AT AND ARE CREATING
THESE KINDS OF PROBLEMS AND IF
THAT IS NOT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE I DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS.
I ALSO WITH WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THERE ARE DIFFERING.
OPINIONS AND POINTS OF VIEW WITH
RESPECT TO WHETHER OR NOT THIS
APPROACH.
A IS MERITORIOUS AYE THINK IT
IS.
A LITTLE BIT ONE SIDED TO.
.
IGNORE THE SUPPORT OF.
AT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S THE
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THE
POLICE CHIEF OUR SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION'S.
THE DEPUTY SHERIFFS UP OF PEOPLE
TREATING A PEOPLE A FOR THESE
KINDS OF ADDICTIONS.
THAT THERE DOES COME A POINT IN
WHICH
A PARTICULAR DRUG AND AND THE.
PURPOSEFUL A WOULDN'T BLENDING
EVIDENT AND SELLING IT TO PEOPLE
RISES TO A LEVEL OF A
SIGNIFICANT.
CRIME THAT SHOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PENALTY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AND I APPRECIATE THE.
A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW HERE
BUT I THINK WE HAVE SEPARATED
DEL.
FROM USERS AND I THINK WE HAVE
RAISED A.
REAL WARNING FLAG.
OVER WHAT CAR FENTON ALL IS
CAPABLE OF DOING EN IS IN DOING
IT AND DOING NOW.
I HOPE I AM NOT. PROPHETIC HERE
I HOPE I'M NOT BACK BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE OR OTHERS COMMITTEE ON
I SERVE ON THE. HAVE SERVED ON
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL I
UNDERSTAND THESE KINDS OF
THINGS.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT I THINK
THERE'S A TICKING TIME BOMB
COMING AND I DO BELIEVE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND.
PENALTIES THAT REALLY DO THAT
THAT SIGNAL VERY CLEARLY THAT
THAT THIS KIND OF DRUG SELLING
IT. I IS GOING TO COME WITH SOME
SEVERE PENALTIES I THINK THAT IS
HELPFUL ALL THINGS CONSIDERED SO
I APPRECIATE YOU HEARING. THE
BILL AND WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON AND I
KNOW.
ON BECAUSE WE'VE
SPOKEN ON THE FLOOR IN AND DAY
OUT SEVERAL CASE I KNOW YOU.
WE GENERALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND NEWT AND YOU TRULY BELIEVE.
ON THAT THIS PARTICULAR
METHODOLOGY IS THE WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND WE'RE ALL ENTITLED TO.
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON HOW TO
COME TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
I WORKED. IN A MORTUARY BUSINESS
FROM.
SEVENTY NINE TO ABOUT NINETEEN
NINETY.
AND I SAW WHAT THE CRACK COCAINE
EPIDEMIC DID I REMEMBER LAWS.
THAT CAME ABOUT HOW AFRAID WE
WERE.
AND HOW WE THOUGHT THREE
STRIKES.
WITH THE WAY.
TO GET OUT OF THE CRACK COCAINE
EPIDEMIC.
BUT ALSO SAW THE NUMBER OF
DAMAGE FAMILIES.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO DIED.
BOTH ON THE CRIMINAL SIDE FROM
SELLING IT IN KILLING EACH OTHER
TO PEOPLE WHO.
SMOKERS CELLS INTO AN EARLY
GRAVE AND FAMILIES JUST
DESTROYED INSIDE.
UNBELIEVABLY SYMPATHETIC.
WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
.
BUT I ALSO NOW THAT THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE USED AT THAT
TIME TRYING TO JAIL AWAY.
OUT OF THE EPIDEMIC
I THINK ULTIMATELY.
PEOPLE.
STOP USING IT OR WE STARTED
USING MORE STARGATE MORE HELP
AND WE JUST STARTED GETTING
HEALTHY.
AND A HEALTHY WE GOT WE KINDA
GOT OUT OF THAT THAT AT THE
CRACK COCAINE EPIDEMIC.
BUT. ANOTHER ONE COMES UP AGAIN
AND AGAIN. AND SO HEALING PEOPLE
AT THE BEGINNING ON. TEACHING
PEOPLE HAVE.
IF THIS GENTLEMAN
WHO ARE TYPICALLY.
SAID AND I AGAIN I.
I CAN FIGURE PASSION FOR FOR
THIS AND I APPRECIATED. NAM.
BUT I'M. I'M HOPEFULLY.
DAVID BEATING JAIL YOU AWAY BUT
WE CAN.
CARSON RATE YOU
THE POINT WHERE YOU GOT OFF
DRUGS THAT YOU'VE GOT SOME KIND
OF.
HELP.
TO TO GET OFF OF THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM SOME OF THE MEMBERS HERE
THAT LET'S GIVE THIS A TRY.
LET'S START. USING YOUR HEALTH
COMMITTEE FUNDING FOR THAT TO GO
AND THEN GET RID OF THE
CUSTOMERS.
AND STOPS INDIVIDUALS FROM
GETTING TRAPPED INTO THAT AND
SO.
THAT'S WHY I RECOMMEND NO VOTE
SO THAT WE CAN.
GET SOMEBODY'S THESE THESE
PROGRAMS
STARTED.
WE CAN START GETTING PEOPLE
FUNNELED INTO THEM AND WE
ULTIMATELY ARE ARE ABLE TO DO
SOME GOOD SAW. UNFORTUNATELY I'M
ENOUGH TO RECOMMEND THE NO VOTE.
HELP.
THAT CYCLICAL ROLE.
ON AB TWENTY FOUR FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. NO JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY LACKEY I CARILLO. CARILLO
NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
SORRY THAT MEASURE FAILS.
YEAH WOULD I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION PLEASE.
AND BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT IF THIS
IF THIS ISN'T THE APPROPRIATE
TIME OR. THAT TALKED WITH MILLER
BUT ABOUT IT. LOOK LATER WHAT BY
ANOTHER RECONSIDERATION I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER. IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IN THE IN THE CAR FENTON A
BILL.
.
WE WERE ALSO SEEKING TO A
ATTITUDE.
.
AS A SCHEDULE.
TO DRUG.
I THINK THAT'S NOT GOING TO DO
ANY ENHANCEMENT THAT'S NOT GOING
TO ADD ANY ADDITIONAL TIME. BUT
WHAT IT WILL DO IS MAKE IT VERY
VERY CLEAR. WITH RESPECT TO
PROSECUTIONS THAT IT IS A IT IS
IT IS IN FACT TAKE A SCHEDULE
TWO DRUG WE CAN DISCUSS IT AFTER
THIS RIGHT NOW THAT BILLS FAILS
BECAUSE I STAND AT. CURRENT BUT
I'M WILLING.
DISCUSS ANYTHING.
YOU WANNA BRING UP CHAIR THANK
YOU.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AYE.
BOB.
OBVIOUSLY PHANTOM ALL IS A MUCH
MORE IDENTIFIABLE.
NAME TO A DRUG AND I THINK WE
ARE ALL.
.
VERY AWARE OF WHAT IT HAS DONE.
THE SACRAMENTO AREA WAS.
INUNDATED WITH.
DEATHS.
WITH RESPECT TO IT SOMETIME
BACK.
IT IS A VERY POWERFUL
ANESTHETIC IT'S FIFTY TIMES MORE
POTENT THAN HEROIN.
A HUNDRED TIMES MORE POTENT THAN
MORPHINE.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THE RAPID
SPREAD OF FENTON ALL IS THAT IT
OFFERS A VERY HIGH PROFIT
MARGIN.
THE TRAFFICKERS.
CHAIRMAN THAT RAISING THE BAR ON
THE PENALTY FOR TRAFFICKERS.
IS A VERY EFFECTIVE WAY A TWO
HERB SHED SOME OF THOSE PROFITS
AND MAKE IT MUCH MORE ENTICING
AN INTERESTING TO DO THE DEED IN
THE FIRST PLACE. I THINK THERE
IS AN IMPORTANT LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASPECT TO THIS
ACCORDING TO THE D. E. A. A
TRAFFICKER.
TYPICALLY PURCHASES A KILOGRAM
OF FEDERAL FOR A FEW THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM A CHINESE SUPPLIER.
EASILY TRANSFORMS THAT INTO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF PILLS.
AND THE.
STREET MARKET.
VALUE TURNS THAT.
THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO MILLIONS
MILLIONS.
OF DOLLARS.
LONG FORSMAN OFFICERS HAVE
SEIZED MORE THAN A KILOGRAM
AFFECT NOW IN LOS ANGELES.
IN SAN FRANCISCO SINCERO CHULA
VISTA AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN.
ADDS A SENTENCING ENHANCEMENT
FOR THE POSSESSION FOR SALE AND
FOR TRANSPORT.
FOR SALE AGAIN WE ARE NOT.
ATTEMPTING TO.
PUNISH THE USER.
BUT TO INSTEAD FOCUS ON THE DRUG
TRAFFICKER.
AND.
I MEAN I I RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE
WE THERE IS A HEALTH COMPONENT
TO THIS.
AND GETTING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE PART ARE HOOKED ON THIS
KIND OF.
OF STUFF THE KIND OF HELP IN THE
IN THE TREATMENT THEY NEED.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THERE IS A
CONSEQUENTIAL SIDE AND THERE IS
ALSO. A A A PUNITIVE SIDE THAT
IN FACT I ACTUALLY BELIEVE.
AND THERE'S.
REPORT THAT THE BILL HAS ARE
FROM INSTITUTIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO SEE A
CONNECTION.
BETWEEN THE TRAFFICKERS.
OF BEING ABLE TO EXTRACT
PENALTIES AN TO ESSENTIALLY
SIGNAL THAT THIS IS THE KIND OF.
THE HORRIBLE DRUG THAT IS.
YEAH.
WORSE CONSEQUENCES IN AN EASIER
FOR TRAFFICKERS.
TO MAKE BIG PROFITS.
I THINK WE GOTTA START CUTTING
INTO THEIR PROFITS AS WELL I
THINK THERE'S A SUPPLY SIDE.
QUESTION I THINK THERE'S A
DEMAND SIDE QUESTION.
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE WE'RE NOT
PUNISHING THE USERS.
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS AND
CARTELS WHO KNOWINGLY.
A GET THESE.
AMOUNTS CUT THEM UP.
AND KILL PEOPLE WITH IT
KNOWINGLY.
I THINK THEY NEED TO.
KNOWINGLY A APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THERE WILL BE ENHANCED
CONSEQUENCES FOR.
THAT KIND OF.
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR.
SO I'M GOING TO ASK FOR SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AGAIN RECOGNIZING
THAT.
.
THERE ARE THE POINTS OF VIEW
THAT ARE. VERY MUCH DIFFERENT
DATA FROM.
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF OF
THE BILL HERE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND IT.
BUT I DO WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM
PAM SMITH IS A CONSTITUENT IN MY
DISTRICT.
AND AGAIN FROM MISTER MISTER
FLINT ANDERSON FOUNDER. OF
PARENTS IN ATTICS IN NEED THEM
THEY HAVE. ABSOLUTE IN SPECIFIC.
EXPERIENCE WITH THE HORRORS OF
PROFESSIONAL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS PAYABLE SPENT.
I'M FROM FRESNO.
MY SON JACKSON SMITH.
DOUBLE EIGHT.
UNDER LIFE THIRD. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
TWENTY ONE MONTHS AGO TODAY.
BECAUSE THE LOCAL DRUG DEALER.
SOLD HIM IN OXYCONTIN THAT WAS
LACED WITH MENTAL.
MY SON WAS TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD.
JACKSON. WHO WAS A VERY?
SPECIAL PERSON. HE WAS.
HE.
WHAT HAVE THE SWEETEST SOUL
ALWAYS KIND AND RESPECTFUL?
TO EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
HE WAS VERY BRIGHT HE WENT TO.
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE AND EARNED A
DEGREE IN MATHEMATICS AND
TRANSFERRED.
TO.
CSU NORTHRIDGE.
AFTER THIRTEEN MONTHS.
OBLIVION IN LA HIS.
ROOMMATES CALLED ME.
TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN.
OVER IS DRUG USAGE.
SO I IMMEDIATELY.
DROVE TELL A PACKED UP AND MOVED
TO MY HOME.
WE ARRIVED ON OCTOBER THE THIRD.
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
I DID EVERYTHING I COULD. TO GET
HIM INTO REHAB.
IN THERAPY.
HE FINALLY AGREED TO THAT.
ON MARCH THE FIFTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN.
A HUNDRED AND NINE DAYS LATER.
HE WAS DEAD.
THE DRUG DEALER.
WHO SOLD?
THE FENTANYL TO MY STOP.
YEAH STILL WALKS THE STREETS OF
SNOW.
AND THIS IS ALL I CAN ONLY
ASSUME.
IT'S STILL SELLING THIS POISON
TO OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
THESE DRUG DEALERS AND CHAPARRAL
FACTORS.
YEAH BOTH SENTINEL THEY NEED
STIFFER PENALTIES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE RUINED LEGAL
LAW HADES.
I IMPLORE YOU TO PASS THIS.
BILL.
BEFORE YOU VOTE.
I'D LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT.
AND YOUR GRANDCHILDREN.
OKAY IN YOUR NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
DO IT FOR THEIR HOME.
IT WILL.
THIS IS WHAT WITH THIS IS WHAT
WE FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
IS WHAT WE FACE IN OUR OFFICE
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
CLOSER AGAIN.
PLEASE CONSIDER THIS BILL.
FOR THIS LADY AND FOR OUR
CILDREN.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
BRENDAN APATHY LA COUNTY SHERIFF
YOU.
A CHAU MUCH ARAB HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ON ON WITH
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MY CONDOLENCES.
MOTHERS AMERICANS GANGS
COALITION AND SUPPORT YOU LIVE
ALONE SUCKERS.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE GOING
BACK AS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE.
TESTIMONY FROM THE PRIOR BILL
APPLIES TO THIS BILL WE'RE
OPPOSED TO. RAPID INCREASES IN
PENALTIES AS A WAY OF ADDRESSING
THIS PROBLEM THANK YOU.
KATHY SHARON THE HAVE THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
IT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES MISTER QUIRK UP FIRST OF ALL
MY CONDOLENCES TO THE WITNESS
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE THE PROBLEM IS THAT THAT
PERSON IS STILL ON THE STREET.
AND NEEDS TO BE TAKEN OFF THE
STREET AND I THINK COULD BE MORE
IMPORTANT.
FOR THE SHERIFF RATHER THAN
HAVING TO PAY FOR ELEVEN MORE
YEARS OF CONFINEMENT TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL DEPUTIES.
AND TO ME THAT IS A MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT AND MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY OF GETTING SOMEONE
LIKE THIS OFF THE STREET
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
AGAIN APPRECIATE.
.
HEARING OUTSIDE.
TO QUICKLY REITERATE PAM'S.
THERE ARE SOME.
.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SOME PEOPLE
WHO ACT IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT MUST RAISE THE PENALTY FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS.
I THINK THOSE REASONS ARE
OBVIOUS NOTWITHSTANDING THE
DEBATE. AND THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAVE HERE I THINK FENTANYL
RISES TO THAT. LEVEL. AND I AM
ASKING YOU TO JOIN WITH HER AND
THOSE.
.
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY THESE
TRAFFICKERS?
AND ALSO WITH THE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
.
AND THOSE ON THE FRONTLINES OF
TRYING TO DO THE JOB THAT WE ASK
HIM TO DO THEY'RE ASKING FOR
THESE KINDS OF ENHANCEMENTS FOR
GOOD AND. PURPOSEFUL REASONS AND
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT THE WITNESS TO KNOW.
I I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR.
ABOUT SIX YEARS.
AND I I CAN TELL DISTANCES BEEN
THE MOST PASSIONATE.
.
TESTIMONY.
I THINK I'VE EVER HEARD TO TYPE
IN HERE.
AND I EVERY MEMBER.
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
US TO GIVE OUR CONDOLENCES.
YOUR POWERFUL POWERFUL SPEAKER.
IN THIS REGARD.
REALLY TOUCHING.
.
BOLLYWOOD THE IMPACT ON. ON YOU.
AND YOUR FAMILY.
THEY ACTUALLY RIGHT. ON NOT
ONLY DO I NEED TO THINK OF.
MY.
TWO SONS AND DAUGHTER BY NOW
HAVE A GRANDSON.
SO I'D. DEFINITELY TAKE THAT
INTO CORRECT IN CONSIDERATION. I
ALSO THINK OF ALL.
THE YOUNG KIDS WHO AREN'T PART
OF MY FAMILY LINEAGE THEY'RE OUT
THERE.
.
THAT MAY HAVE.
RESORTED TO TO EAT TO USING THIS
DRUG.
AND INDIVIDUALS BATUM.
DAD ARE.
USING IT AGAINST US
AND AND AND SO IT JUST REALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE.
WERE GOING WE WANT TO GOING
INTO DIRECTION.
AND WE WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT SO THAT.
.
AND I'VE SUIT YOU CAN'T WITH NO
EXCHANGE TO PASS SO I CAN.
CONTINUE TO GIVE YOU.
MY CONDOLENCES AND LET YOU KNOW
HOW HEARTFELT THAT IS.
.
AND FOR HIM STE PATTERSON I'M
AFTER RECOMMEND THE NO.
BUT I'M ALSO GOING TO.
.
ASK YOU.
TO ALLOW ME AND THE COMMITTEE.
TO WORK WITH YOU.
ON FOCUSING LIKE A LASER.
YOU SAID ON GOING AFTER.
I TRAFFICKERS AYE DETER SOME
WORDING IN HERE.
THAT.
BOTHERS ME IN THEM PASSAM.
CONCERNS THAT WE WILL. END UP IN
THE SAME PLACE WE WERE WITH
CRACK COCAINE OR WEAKENED UP
BLOCKING UP.
MORE USER SLASH.
DEALERS.
DAMN WE ARE GETTING TO THE CRUX
OF.
CUTTING OFF THE FLOW.
AND AND SO OUT OF IT.
AND I'M HOPING THAT IT.
THAT WE'D WE'D SAY NO BUT I'M
ALSO HOPEFUL THAT. US FOR
RECONSIDERATION SO WE CAN WORK
ON THIS TOGETHER.
SEARCHERS RECKON UNFORTUNATELY
OF REGRETFULLY AND IVORY AYE I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
SENTIMENT.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU
BELIEVE IN YOUR HEART.
WHAT WE ALL BELIEVE IN OUR
HEART?
ON THE ON ON ON THE SIDE OF
STARTING OVER HELPING PEOPLE
WHO.
SO THANK YOU SO YES WE OF AB
TWENTY HER SIX TO SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED IN THE FACT.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR SIX SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED YOUR
PREPARATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY. LACKEY I
CARILLO.
PRETTY ARE NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NO.
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NO.
UNFORTUNATE MEASURE FAILED THAT
WE ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION BUT
MORE THAN YOUR MANAGER ASIAN.
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE OPEN
DOOR TO MOVE ON WITH THIS.
YOUR MAN OF YOUR WORD AND NOT
AND I HOPE.
I AM TOO. AND I WANT TO BE A
PART OF THIS WITH YOU AND AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE. DAY OUT
REACH THAT YOU HAVE SUGGESTED
TODAY VERY VERY MUCH THANK I
WANNA MAKE SURE WE HONOR HER AND
HER SON.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MOVE.
I HAVE STEINORTH BEEN
CUNNINGHAM.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE WILL
HELP SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM
THE ABUSIVE SITUATIONS WHILE
MAINTAINING FINANCIAL SECURITY
AND THE SAFETY OF THEIR PATHS.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT OVER
FORTY NINE PERCENT OF FEMALE
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
REPORTED THREAT OR HARM TO THEIR
PADS.
THIS FEAR OF ABUSE TWO A VICTIMS
PAT HAS BECAUSE UP TO FORTY
PERCENT OF FEMALE SURVIVORS TO
DELAY LEAVING AN ABUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT. DUE TO THE CONCERN
THAT THEY HAVE FOR THEIR PET
SAFETY.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE SEEKS TO
REMEDY THIS OBSTACLE FOR
SURVIVORS BY EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD RESTITUTION FUNDS LIST. OF
A.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
HI I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO CHIME IN.
I THAT'S WHY I'M OUTSIDE THOUGH
TALK BEST YES.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WHAT LISA LA DEFY
YOURSELF AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
IT SEEMS THAT CALIFORNIA PART
EXCEPT ANIMUS OF VIOLENCE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF SUSAN RATES
WITH THAT AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
THE PREVENTION OF CRUELTY TO
ANIMALS HAS CO SPONSORED WITH
PARTNERS THINK.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE THE FIRST AND SECOND MAY CALL
THE ROLL. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE CLOSER I
LACKEY.
LACKEY I GOT RIO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR.
TO CUNNINGHAM.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN WITH ME TODAY IS.
YOU WE OWE ALONZO GARZA WHO'S
THE FOUNDER OF MOTHER'S AND MEN
AGAINST GANGS COALITION.
AND OUTSIDE TREVOR MACAM FROM
THE SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
I'D LIKE TO.
NO THAT I AND THE JOINT AUTHORED
THIS MEASURE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA BUT HE COULDN'T BE
WITH US TODAY SOME PRESENTING.
FOR BOTH OF US AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH WE
ACCEPT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE NAME OF
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES TO GANG
CRIMES.
I CAN BE ACCESSED USING A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE THAT
WHERE A VICTIM OR A WITNESS TO A
GANG CRIME REQUESTS
CONFIDENTIALITY. THEIR NAME
WOULD BE REDACTED. AND ANY
REPORTS AND DOCUMENTS.
BEFORE THOSE DOCUMENTS OR
RELEASED PURSUANT TO PR A
REQUEST.
SIMILAR CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS EXISTING CURRENT LAW
FOR VICTIMS OF SEX CRIMES AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
OFFENSES BUT NOT TO GANG RELATED
OFFENSES ON THIS BILL WOULD. AT
A MODEST LAYER PROTECTION TO
VICTIMS OR WITNESSES.
AND HOPEFULLY DETER WITNESS
INTIMIDATION EFFORTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS GOVERNMENT CAM THE
SERGEANT WITH THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
.
THIS LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
I MADE THIS LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
FIDEL.
I MADE THIS LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL.
A TO ASSEMBLYMAN COURT
CUNNINGHAM'S OFFICE ON THIS
RESULT OF SOME EXPERIENCE AND A
PARTICULAR CASE THAT I
INVESTIGATED IN. JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. ASKING ME.
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD I WAS
ASSIGNED AS A GANG DETECTIVE TO
THE SALAS WAS WILL COUNTY GANG
TASK FORCE.
AND WAS INVESTIGATING. A CASE IN
WHICH A FOR FRESNO BULLDOGS.
CAME TO APPLE BEACH.
AND.
ASSAULTED A GROUP OF FRIENDS
THAT WERE AT A FARMER'S MARKET.
I DURING THIS IS THE ASSAULT WAS
A RESULT.
OF A BRIEF.
A REFUSAL OF HAVEN'T ADVANCED
THAT ONE OF THE OTHER GANG
MEMBERS IT MAY TOWARDS OF ONE OF
THE FEMALE VICTIMS.
THE THE BULLDOGS DECIDED IN
RETALIATION THAT WOULD RESULT
THESE FRIENDS.
AND DURING THE COURSE OF THE
ASSAULT.
ONE OF THE THE GAMING MEMBERS
PICKED UP A PARTIALLY FULL
CORONA BEER BOTTLE AND THREW IT.
AT THE FEMALE VICTIM SAID
CAUSING A SKULL FRACTURE IN A
LARGE LACERATION REQUIRED
MEDICAL TREATMENT AT A HOSPITAL.
AS I WAS CONDUCTING FALL OF
INVESTIGATION AND IDENTIFIED.
TWO DIFFERENT COUPLES.
THAT WERE WITNESSES IN THIS
CASE.
THEY WERE CONSIDERED REALLY GOOD
WITNESSES.
AND THEY HAD SEEN THE WHOLE
ATTACK.
THEY'RE UNBIASED THEY HAD NO
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
SUSPECTS OR THE VICTIMS.
AND THEY WERE ARTICULATE AND
BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WHAT
THEY SAW EFFECTIVELY.
A ONE OF THE ONE OF THESE BIG
ERRORS EXCUSE ME ONE OF THESE
WITNESSES WAS A REGISTERED NURSE
SHE PROVIDED MEDICAL AID TO THE
VICTIM ON SCENE WHILE WAITING
FOR THE AMBULANCE TO ARRIVE.
AS AS A SPEAKING TO.
THIS
THIS WITNESS.
AND WE BEGAN TALKING ABOUT WHAT
TYPE PROTECTIONS SHE HAD AS A
WITNESS SHE KNEW THAT THE
SUSPECTS IN THIS CASE WERE
BULLDOGS SHOOTS PER MILLION WITH
THAT GANG.
AND SHE WAS FEARFUL OF
RETALIATION AGAINST HERSELF
MISTER FAMILY.
AND AGAINST HER HUSBAND.
WHEN EXPLAINED TO HER THAT. ON
HER NAME WOULD BE INCLUDED IN
THE POLICE REPORT.
SHE DECIDED THAT SHE DID NOT
WANT TO COOPERATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE INVESTIGATION
REQUESTED THAT ALL.
DOCUMENTATION ON.
BE.
.
STOPPED IN HER INTERVIEW.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS KIND OF A
COMMON EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE
IS AS GANG.
DETECTIVES AND INVESTIGATORS.
MANY CRIMES GO UNREPORTED OR IF
THEY ARE REPORTED THEIR.
.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SOLVE THEM
BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT TO HAVE
WITNESSES THAT ARE WILLING TO
ASSIST US.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS THIS BILL
WOULD.
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL.
OF.
COMFORTING WITNESSES THAT DO
WANT TO HELP AND THE SUCH
INVESTIGATIONS PERFECT BETTER
FEARFUL OF RETALIATION.
AND THIS LEGISLATION IN NO WAYS
INTENDED TO CIRCUMVENT DISCOVERY
REQUIREMENTS IN CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS.
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS SIXTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO CONFRONT
WITNESSES AGAINST HIM OR HER.
WILL NOT BE INFRINGED ON BY THIS
LEGISLATION.
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY WOULD STILL
BE PROVIDED.
WITH ALL IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
OF WITNESSES NECESSARY.
TO MOUNT A COMPETENT AND
REASONABLE DEFENSE FOR THEIR
CLIENT.
I STRONGLY.
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL I THINK THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAYS TO ASSISTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MAKING ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY SAFER THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THINK THANK YOU. AND
YET ONE MORE MINUTE DO YOU
WANNA.
YOU NO ALONSO GARZA FOUNDER. OF
MOTHER'S EGGMAN AGAINST BANKS
COALITION.
MOTHER AND VOICE OF MARTINEZ BUT
THE CARS OF.
WHOM WAS TAKEN.
ON JANUARY SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN BY A GANG MEMBER.
IN JANUARY I CAME BEFORE YOU'RE
SIMPLY.
WITH.
ASSEMBLYMAN.
NUMBER OF THE AUTHOR GARCIA. AND
ALL OF YOU.
AGREED UPON ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE A GANG PROBLEM.
AND IT IT'S TIME TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT GANG PROBLEM.
I THINK ACR ONE THIRTY FOUR.
DECLARING JANUARY GANG AWARENESS
AND PREVENTION MONTH WAS THE
FIRST STEP WE NEEDED TO TAKE.
I FEEL FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
GIVEN A VOICE HERE AS A MOTHER.
BUT I ASK RESPECTFULLY
TO GIVE ME.
TWO ADDITIONAL MINUTES FOR MY
SON AND TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED.
JANUARY FIFTH.
MY SON WENT OUT WITH THE SISTER.
AND UNFORTUNATELY MATT.
WITH.
SOME FRIENDS AND DECIDED TO
MEET.
NEW PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY A COUPLE OF DAYS
BEFORE THAT
PERPETRATOR WAS RELEASED ON A
PLEA DEAL BECAUSE. THERE WAS A
LACK OF WITNESSES DUE TO THE
LACK OF PROTECTION FOR GANG
CRIME. WITNESSES AND VICTIMS.
PERSON DID MINIMUM TIME.
WAS RELEASED ON THURSDAY.
AND ON SATURDAY NIGHT.
IT KILLED MY SON.
AND CHANGED
MY JOURNEY.
AND. MY FAMILY'S FUTURE FOR
EVER.
FOUR DAYS LATER ON JANUARY TENTH
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
I DECIDED
I PUT MY PURSE DOWN AS A MOTHER.
AS
A COMMUNITY MEMBER AS A TEACHER.
TO MAKE SURE THAT NOTHER FAMILY
DID NOT EXPERIENCE THIS.
I HAVE TAKEN IT UPON.
MYSELF AND THOSE THAT SUPPORT
US.
TO ENSURE THAT VICTIMS VOICES
ARE HEARD.
I SAT HERE
FOR ABOUT TWO AND HALF HOURS
LISTENING TO SO MANY.
CASES.
AND ALMOST EVERY TIME I WANTED
TO GET UP AND SAY SOMETHING
BECAUSE IT.
IT RELATED SO MUCH TO MY SON'S
CASE.
BUT TODAY. I WANT TO ASK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO PUT YOUR
PURSE DOWN LIKE MY FAMILY DEAD.
LIKE THE WITNESSES.
THAT WE WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE.
AGAINST.
EVERY NOW AND.
GANG MEMBERS THAT HAD NOT BEEN
ABLE TO BE STOPPED.
AND IT WAS THROUGH THE PASSION
AND THE NURTURING THAT OUR
FAMILY DID.
FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF THESE
WITNESSES
THAT WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE JUSTICE.
BUT NOT JUST OUR FAMILY DESERVES
JUST.
ALL FAMILIES
OF GANG CRIME DESERVE JUSTICE.
I'M PROTECTION.
AND I ASK THAT EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU PLEASE VOTE IN FAVOR. AND
SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM'S
LEGISLATION.
A BLACK TWENTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
CHEN MEMBERS ARE SHOWN MUCH
LOBBY HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
FIRST LET ME EXPRESS MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE WITNESS WHO
JUST SPOKE.
AND SAY.
WE AGREE THAT ALL THAT ALL
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA DESERVE
JUSTICE.
AND THAT CUTE INCLUDES BOTH THE
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS AND THE
FAMILIES OF PERSONS WHO ARE
ACCUSED OF GRANT AND CRIMES AND
OTHER CRIMES.
WE BELIEVE THAT PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE PROTECTION OF LIBERTY.
FOR ALL OF US.
THE POWER EXERCISED BY THE
GOVERNMENT IN CRIMINAL CASES IS
THE GREATEST OF GOVERNMENTAL
POWERS THE POWER TO DEPRIVE AN
INDIVIDUAL OF HIS LIBERTY.
THE NEED TO EXERCISE THAT POWER
OAK OPEN TO PUBLIC VIEW IS
EXPRESSED IN THE SIXTH AMENDMENT
OF THE CONSTITUTION. WHICH
PROTECTS THE RIGHT OF THE
ACCUSED TO A PUBLIC TRIAL AND TO
CONFRONT WITNESSES AGAINST HIM.
I AM IN CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT FURTHER SUPPORTS
PUBLIC OVERSIGHT OF THE CUP
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. BY
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO THE RECORDS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND CAN
REVIEW IN ONE CASE OR AS TO MANY
CASES WHETHER JUSTICE IS BEING
DONE.
WE WOULD ARGUE THAT KEEPING A
STE CASES OPEN TO PUBLIC USE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN GANG
CASES WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE
PROSECUTED NOT SOLELY ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR ACTIONS BUT ALSO
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE OVERSIGHT
THAT IS PROVIDE PROVIDED UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT IS BALANCE ALREADY BALANCED
AGAINST THE NEED TO PROTECT
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION SIXTY
TWO FIFTY FOUR F. EXPRESSLY
STATES THAT THE NAMES AND
ADDRESSES OF VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
DISCLOSURE WHERE DISCLOSURE
WOULD QUOTE. ENDANGER THE SAFETY
OF A WITNESS OR OTHER PERSON
INVOLVED IN THE INVESTIGATION OR
WOULD ENDANGER THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE INVESTIGATION
OR RELATED INVESTIGATION.
WE THINK THOSE PROTECTIONS AND
THE BALANCE THAT THAT STRIKES IS
IS APPROPRIATE.
WE THINK THAT AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN IS UNNECESSARY. VICTIMS
AND WITNESSES ARE ALREADY
PROTECTED WHEN THEIR SAFETY IS
THREATENED. AND WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO IS IN ANY
CASE WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
ANY SUGGESTION THAT THERE WAS
SUCH A THREAT.
TO.
TO KEEP THAT INFORMATION FROM
BEING DISCLOSED UPON A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST AND.
I I HAVE NOT AT LEAST HEARD
TESTIMONY THAT THAT.
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST ARE
BEING USED ITEM IN ORDER FOR.
AYE OTHER GANG MEMBERS TO TO GET
ACCESS TO THE NAMES AND
ADDRESSES OF VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES SUCH SO AS TO. ENGAGE
IN RETALIATION AGAINST.
TOM. WE BELIEVE THE PROSECUTION
OF GANG CRIMES AS OF OTHER
CRIMES NEEDS PUBLIC OVERSIGHT
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE SO
THAT INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
PROSECUTIONS IS NOT POINTLESSLY
WITH HELD FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
THANK YOU FOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER QUIRK YA I THINK THIS IS
A NECESSARY BUILT PROTECT
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN SURE.
PROSECUTION AND. AGAIN.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE BILL
AND.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
CAN DO TO. TO GET RID OF CRIMES
IS TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WILLING TO TESTIFY. AND IT IS
THE CERTAINTY OF.
SOMEONE BEING FOUND OUT
CONVICTED FOR CRIME THIS THE WAY
TO PREVENT THEM. AND I BELIEVE
THAT THIS.
FOSTER STATS SO I'LL BE VOTING
FOR YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MOST CUNNINGHAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THANK YOU
THANK YOU AN DOT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
ON ON THE AMENDMENTS I THINK IT.
IS THE LEAST GOT ME TO WHERE
I'M.
RECOMMENDING THAT I ENJOYED AYE
RECOMMENDATION. OF.
IT IN CONTINUE TO TO TO LISTEN
TO TO OTHERS WHO.
WHO HAVE CONCERNS AND AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD IF YOU CAN FIND ANY
WAY TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS PLEASE SO? I KNOW YOU
WELL.
SURE THAT YOU'LL LISTEN TO THEM
SO.
TO GET THE MOTION.
A MOTION SECOND.
SELECT AB TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SAN DIEGO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
RELATIONS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR FOR TESTIFIED.
TO GALLAGHER.
TWENTY TWO NINETY.
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
IT'S ALWAYS A PLEASURE. TO BE IN
YOUR COMMITTEE.
AT THIS MORNING AND SO TODAY I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT.
AB TWO TWO NINE ZERO.
WHICH WOULD EXPAND POST
CONVICTION RESTRAINING ORDERS.
TO PROTECT ALL WITNESSES
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO IN MANY
CASES OUR CHILDREN.
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
THEIR IMMEDIATE.
FAMILY MEMBERS OFTEN NEED
GREATER PROTECTION POST
CONVICTION.
THAN THEY DO PRE CONVICTION
UNDER CURRENT LAW. THE COURT THE
COURT MAY ISSUE A POST
CONVICTION RESTRAINING ORDER.
PROTECTING THE VICTIM THEMSELVES
AND A PERCIPIENT WITNESS.
THOSE WHO HAVE WITNESSED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND HAVE BEEN
CALLED UPON.
TO TESTIFY.
HOWEVER THE COURT RIGHT NOW AS
POWERLESS TO ISSUE A POST
CONVICTION RESTRAINING ORDER.
PROTECTING A WITNESS OF THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
INCIDENT WHO DID NOT TESTIFY IN
COURT. UNLESS THEY CAN PROVE
THAT THEY'RE IN DANGER AND IN
MANY CASES THESE ARE CHILDREN.
A EVEN IF THE DEFENDANT IS NOT
PHYSICALLY ABUSED A MINOR IN THE
PAST OR IF THE MINOR DID NOT
TESTIFY AGAINST THE DEFENDANT.
THE MINOR WHO WITNESSED THESE
AXES STILL. IN IMMINENT
PHYSICAL%
DANGER AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
WOULD EXPAND THE IMPORTANT
PROTECTION OF POST CONVICTION
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
TO INCLUDE ALL WITNESSES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE NOT JUST
PERCIPIENT WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AT US
FOR AYE VOTE I DON'T HAVE WITH
ME A WITH THIS.
SORRY OF.
NOT A WITNESS BUT THE.
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL ORDER
LARRY DOYLE.
OKAY
IF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED IN THE
LEGISLATURE EVENTUALLY ENACTED
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
WHICH FILLED A GAP.
WITH REGARD TO PROTECTIVE
CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
.
PREVIOUSLY YOU KNOW IT THIS IS
PRE CONVICTION PROTECTIVE
ORDERS.
PREVIOUSLY YOU COULD ONLY.
APPLY THOSE PROTECTIVE ORDERS TO
THE VICTIMS OR YOU COULD DO
PERCIPIENT WITNESSES BUT. YOU
COULD NOT DO WITNESSES EVEN
THOSE WHO ACTUALLY WITNESSED THE
CRIME UNLESS THEY ACTUALLY
TESTIFIED.
WHICH LEFT VULNERABLE MOSTLY
YOUNG CHILDREN WHO WEREN'T ABLE
TO.
YOU COULDN'T PUT IN THERE THE
SITUATION BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
TESTIFY COMPETENTLY OR YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO PUT THEM THROUGH
THE TRAUMA OF TESTIFY.
AND SO WE EXPANDED THE
DEFINITION OF WITNESS TO
INCLUDE.
THESE YOUNG CHILDREN BASICALLY
THAT'S OF THAT WAS THE TARGET.
DEMOGRAPHIC WHO WE WERE LOOKING
TO PROTECT.
WE DIDN'T DO THAT HOWEVER AT
THE TIME FOR POST CONVICTION.
ORDERS
THAT'S WHAT AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
DOES IT TAKES THE SAME. CONCEPT
OF WITNESSES THE YOUNG CHILDREN
AND ALLOWS THEM TO BE PROTECTED
IT BY EXPANDING THE OF
PROTECTIVE ORDERS THAT ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE NOW FOR THE.
OF VICTIMS AND FOR PERCIPIENT
WITNESSES UNDER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW'S BILL FOR LAST YEAR.
JUST TRYING TO FILL IN SOME OF
THE BLANKS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE AN ANOMALOUS
SITUATION WHERE. YOU CAN PROTECT
ANYBODY EXCEPT THE KIDS WHO MAY
HAVE SEEN THE WITH THE USE. OF
BUT COULD NOT BE.
COULD NOT TESTIFY IN THE EARLIER
SITUATION.
WE ALSO LAST YEAR WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON THIS BILL.
ORDER IS SIMILAR BILL. WEEK GOV
ADDED A MEANS WHEREBY YOU CAN
GUARANTEE THAT THEY.
DEFENDANT IN A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASE COULD UP GET OF.
GO RANGE FOR.
.
DOES SEEK CUSTODY OR VISITATION.
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AND.
.
IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY BUT WE HOPE
YOU WILL VOTE YES ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS SESSION WE'RE SEEING BILL
AFTER BILL THAT IT TRIES TO.
THAT ASKED TO EXPAND OUT SPAM
THE COURT'S POWER TO ISSUE POST
CONVICTION RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE BELIEVE IT THIS IS AN
EXPANSION BEYOND THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF OF WHAT THOSE
RESTRAINING ORDERS WE'RE MEANT
TO DO WHICH WAS TO PROTECT.
VICTIMS IN VERY SPECIFIC KINDS
OF CASES ARM.
AFTER I'D DEFENDANT WAS RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY.
WHERE THERE WAS REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT
PARTICULAR VICTIM?
MIGHT SUFFER FURTHER HARM IT AT
THE THE HANDS OF THE DEFENDANT.
.
WE'RE SEEING THIS EXPANSION. AT
THE TO A KIND OF.
.
EXTENSION OF CONTROL OF THE
COMMUNAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHERE
THERE'S NOT THAT SAME TYPE OF
VERY SPECIFIC THREAT. ON TO BE
VERY CLEAR THE THESE ORDERS KEEP
DEFENDANTS UNDER THE CONTROL OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR
A PERIOD THAT CAN BE FAR LONGER
THAN THE PERIOD OF THE SENTENCE
OR EVEN. FROM WHEN THEY'RE ON ON
PAROLE OR PROBATION FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS
IT CAN MAKE IT THAT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO
RE INTEGRATE INTO THE COMMUNITY
AFTER RELEASE. AS WHEN THE TERMS
OF THE ORDER MAKE IT SO THAT THE
PERSON CANNOT GO BACK TO THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR.
TO A FAMILY HOME.
WHERE ARE THE OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS OTHER THAN THE VICTIM UP
MIGHT BE ABLE TO?
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THAT
PERSON'S REINTEGRATION.
WE CERTAINLY AGREE THAT CHILDREN
WHO WITNESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DESERVE PROTECTION AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES FOR THAT
PROTECTION IN THE APPROPRIATE
MANNER.
THROUGH THE FAMILY CODE
PROVISIONS FOR ISSUANCE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS.
THOSE ORDERS CAN INCLUDE ORDERS
TO PROTECT CHILDREN OR OTHER
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS WHO ARE
WITNESSES TO ABUSE.
THE PROVISIONS UNLIKE THE
PROVISIONS PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
RECOGNIZE THAT THE PERSON WHO IS
SUBJECT TO SUCH AN ORDER MAY
WELL BE THE PARENT OF THE
CHILDREN INVOLVED.
IT IS TO SAY THE LEAST A
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
ONE WHERE THE COURT NEEDS TO
BALANCE THE NUMBER OF COMPETING
INTERESTS.
NEEDS TO HAVE TOOLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL BEYOND.
.
SIMPLY TELLING THE.
THE INDIVIDUAL TO BE RESTRAINED
THAT THEY ARE RESTRAINED BUT FOR
EXAMPLE IN FAMILY COURT DATE
THERE ARE ORDERS TO PROVIDE FOR
A SUPERVISED VISITATION IN SOME
CASES WHERE THE PERSON IS
OTHERWISE RESTRAINED FROM SEEING
THOSE CHILDREN.
WE THINK THAT FAMILY COURTS
HAVE THE EXPERTISE. THAT IS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THIS KIND
OF DIFFICULT BALANCING IN A WAY
THAT CRIMINAL COURT SIMPLY DO
NOT.
AND WE OUT STATE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT ASK THE
CRIMINAL COURTS TO DO THE JOB
THAT THE FAMILY COURTS ARE
ALREADY DOING. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NOVEL.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ARE NAY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE QUIRK.
UP SO MISTER DOYLE ERA
REPRESENTING TAKE OUR
ASSOCIATIONS ZACHAREK CONVERTS A
CALIFORNIA MURATSUCHI YES.
.
SO UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THEY CAN FIT THE JUDGES CAN
ISSUE A RESTRAINING ORDER IS AN
A IS SET THAT'S CORRECT AND
UNDER THIS LAW.
IT WOULD STILL BE OPTIONAL.
FOR THE JUDGES TO ISSUE A
RESTRAINING ORDER.
YOU'RE SIMPLY.
ALLOWING THAT RESTRAINING ORDER
TO TO. TO ALSO.
AFFECT A TRIAL.
BUT AGAIN THAT IS THAT'S AT THE
JUDGE'S DISCRETION OF I GOT THAT
RIGHT YES YOU'RE CORRECT. SO
THIS IS ALL WITH THE JUDGE'S
DISCRETION.
SO FOR THE ACLU Y. AND VOTED
AGAINST SOME OF THESE LAWS WHICH
TO EXPAND THAT PROHIBITION. BUT
IN THIS CASE IF A JUDGE SHE SITS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT CHILD I'VE
GOT TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE HE'S ALSO ISSUE WE WANT
TO PROTECT MOTHER. SO I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS ADDS A.
PARTICULARLY ONEROUS.
REQUIREMENT IN TERMS OF SOMEONE
STAYING AWAY.
.
DO YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW ON
THAT.
WELL AGAIN I WOULD RAISE THE
SITUATION WHERE FOR ABOUT FIRST
I I WOULD SAY IN MANY OF THOSE
THOSE CASES THE RESTRAINING
ORDER STAYING THE STAY AWAY FROM
THE MOTHER WHO NAM WOULD ALSO.
AS A MATTER OF PRACTICE PROTECT
THE CHILDREN.
THE CASES WHERE THAT'S NOT GOING
TO BE TRUE I THINK ARE THE ONES
WHERE THOSE CHILDREN ARE THE
CHILDREN OF THE. THE PERSON WHO
WHO IS THE DEFENDANT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE I
THINK THAT A FAMILY COURT HAS
OF.
BETTER ABILITY TO.
.
ADDRESS ALL OF ALL OF THE
INTERESTS IN THE SITUATION AND.
AND CRAFT IN ORDER THAT MANY.
RESTRICT THE PERSON FROM CONTACT
WITH THOSE CHILDREN MOST WHILE
STILL ALLOWING FOR EXAMPLE
VISITATION.
BECAUSE.
THAT PERSON HAS AN INTEREST IN
MAINTAINING A RELATIONSHIP WITH
WITH HIS OR HER CHILDREN.
SO I IF I UNDERSTAND THIS THEN
MISTER DOYLE.
THIS WOULD TRANSFERRED THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. AWAY WHO WHO HAS
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
REALLY RAINING ORDER FOR THE
MOTHER.
IS THAT IN FAMILY COURT OR IN
CRIMINAL COURT.
WELL THE THE ORIGINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDER COMES OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
COURT MUSIC CRIMINAL GETS A
PROTECTIVE ORDER WHICH IT WE
ARE.
PROPOSING IS EXPANDED HE CAN BE
CAN BE EXPANDED UNDER.
APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
YEAH AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT. TO INCLUDE THE.
ESSENTIALLY THE CHILDREN AND
VERY OFTEN THE CHILDREN OF THE
MARRIAGE OR THE RELATIONSHIP.
BUT A WHAT DID THE BILL PROVIDE
SPECIFICALLY THAT YOU DO HAVE. A
SITUATION WHERE YOU CAN EITHER
AT THE TIME OF THE ISSUANCE OF
THE ORDER. HE THEY'VE. TAKEN A.
AND PROVIDE FOR.
THE FAMILY COURT TO MAKE
CONSIDERATION. DOWNSTREAM OR AT
THAT TIME FOR APPROPRIATE.
VISITATION OR CUSTODY
ARRANGEMENTS INCLUDING
SUPERVISED VISITATION IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. OF WHERE WERE AND
THEY ARE PREPARED PASSING IT
ALONG TO THE FAMILY COURT ORDER
CAN HAPPEN.
FARTHER DOWN THE LINE BUT CANNOT
HAPPEN EX PARTE.
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE HAPPENED BE
HAPPEN AND NOTICED HEARING. YOU
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE BE SURE THAT
THE PARENTS.
OR THAT THE MOTHER THE GUARDIANS
OF THE CHILD ARE ENGAGED AND
THAT THE PROSECUTOR FROM THE
INITIAL CASE WHO IS AWARE OF THE
EXTENT OF THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IS ALSO NOTIFIED AND IS ALSO
BEING ABLE TO BE BROUGHT INTO
THE SITUATION SO THAT WE ARE
GUARANTEED THAT THE INTERESTS OF
THE CHILD ARE GOING TO BE PART
FULLY PROTECTED UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO THE FAMILY COURT COULD STILL
MAKE ASSIST DECISION TO ALLOW.
SUPERVISED.
.
OKAY.
THEN I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAKE. ME CLOSER TO GALLAGHER
AYE DISASTER AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND UP AND
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
OF MISTER QUIRK OF.
BECAUSE IT SEEMED LIKE OF
JURISDICTIONAL. AND AND AND I DO
BELIEVE FAMILY COURT. MAY HAVE
MORE EXPERTISE MAY HAVE LOVED A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING IN.
AND MAY EVEN BE A LITTLE
SENSITIVE TO FAMILY SITUATIONS
FUND GLAD THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
IF THERE'S.
WAY TO.
TO PUT SOME VERBIAGE IN NEAR SO
THAT THE FAMILY COURT CAN BE
INVOLVED.
BY WHICH.
I WOULD SUGGEST AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD OF TO LOOK IN THAT
INSULAR CHAIRED YEAR ENJOYING
AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JOXER
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSED
JUST AS A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION.
THE BILL YOU JUST MOVE WAS AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN.
THE NARCOTICS REGISTRATION OF.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN WOULD
DELETE THE CURRENT REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENT FOR A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FROM THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE. EVERY CAR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DESTROYED ON
A COMICS OFFENDER REGISTRATION
RECORDS AS THEY ARE CURRENTLY ON
FILE.
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY
THE CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATION HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN AFTER MY ANY
QUESTIONS.
AGAIN IS LARRY DOYLE.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECT LAST WE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR.
MRS OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
A LARGE OIL ON BEHALF OF THE
CONVERTS CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS.
.
THE PRINCIPAL THING THAT AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN DOES IS
ELIMINATES REQUIREMENT OF THE
CREATION NARCOTICS REGISTRY
BECAUSE.
QUITE FRANKLY IT.
IT IS A REQUIREMENT THAT DOESN'T
REALLY BENEFIT ANYBODY.
IT IS A REQUIREMENT THAT.
SPEND TAKES SO UNLIKELY THE
CITY OF.
THOSE SOCKS RIGID SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION.
A PROCESS THERE IS NO WEBSITE OR
ANYTHING ELSE WERE YOU LOOKING
FOR NOCKARD EX OFFENDERS.
IT IS.
A CASE WHERE OFFENDERS ARE FIRST
TO REGISTER WHICH TAKES THEIR
TIME IT TAKES A TIME OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHICH ALREADY KNOWS
THE INFORMATION THAT'S THERE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE. NOBODY REALLY
CARES NOBODY BENEFITS
WE SHOULD USE THE GA RESOURCES
TO DO. MORE IMPORTANT THINGS.
.
GO GIVES MORE IMPORTANT CRIMES.
A.
THERE WERE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
I BELIEVE THERE WERE.
OKAY OKAY. WHERE AND WHAT IF? IF
I WAS ABLE TO TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS UP TAKEN. CARE.
I'M NOT IT WASN'T SURE OF IT
ANYWAY.
.
OKAY.
LET'S GO THERE THERE IS A
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT WAS
IT ISSUE WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
REGARDING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND THE.
WHO HAVING TO DO WITH TEACHERS?
CURRENTLY UNDER EXISTING LAW
THE SHERIFFS ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT. TO OF THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT MONEY.
TEACHER IS ARRESTED.
.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS ALSO REQUIRED TO BAKE
A SIMILAR REPORT. SO THERE'S
REALLY NOT A LOT OF BENEFIT TO
THAT ADDITIONAL.
REQUIREMENT TO AND THE IDEA OF
REPORTING. ON THE AT A. THE FACT
OF AN ARREST.
IS THERE. NO.
CAN A PRE JUDGMENT ON THE
TEACHER BECAUSE ARREST DOES NOT
MEAN CONVICTION DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THERE WAS. OF PROBABLE
CAUSE EVEN NECESSARILY IT JUST
SIMPLY MEANS THAT SOMEBODY WAS
ARRESTED FOR A CRIME. AND YOU
COULD HAVE A VERY DELETERIOUS
EFFECT ON A TEACHER'S CAREER FOR
NO GOOD PURPOSE
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT
WE'RE DOING I BELIEVE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AS THEY WERE
PRESENTED TO ME. IS TO REMOVE
THAT REQUIREMENT THE BILL LEAVE
IT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DO WHAT. NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT. OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE THAT.
.
OR THAT THE TEACHERS ARE AWARE.
OR THE THE OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE AWARE OF THAT THEIR PROBLEMS
WITH THE TEACHERS AND.
.
ACT IT THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS
BUT WE ARE GOING TO WORK WITH
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO MAKE
SURE THIS CLARIFICATION.
SO WE DON'T HAVE REDUNDANCY
THANK IT IS REPORTED. IS
REPORTED DOJ AND WOOD WHERE
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE WE WORK TO
CHERISH TOOK TO ENSURE THAT ITS
REPORT IT SOMEWHERE. AND THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE ONUS ON BOTH OF
THEM AT THE SAME TIME.
MY APOLOGIES FOR THE COMMITTEE.
I'M STILL CONFUSED LET'S LET'S
MOVE FORWARD.
.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YET MEDI HIRED CALIFORNIA'S
HILLARY'S ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT.
CATHY SURE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
GAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
ABOUT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SO YEAH IT'S SO THAT THERE'S NOT
ANY CONFUSION.
THE INTENTION OF THE BILL IS
THAT THERE'D STILL BE REPORT IF
TEACHERS ARRESTED FOR DRUGS.
ARE IN THAT WOULD COME FROM DOJ
IS THAT CORRECT.
CRAP QUE.
ON.
I SAY THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME HAVING HAD A DAUGHTER.
WHO WAS TAUGHT BY SOMEONE WITH A
DRUG PROBLEM WAS NEVER SOLVED
EVENTUALLY?
WAS BEATEN TO THE POINT WHERE
HE BECAME A.
I HAD TO INDICATE WHEN INTO A
VEGETATIVE STATE SO FOR BOTH HIM
AND MY DAUGHTER IT WAS JUST A
TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE.
AND I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT TO A SCHOOL DISTRICTS BE
INFORMED AND SINCE THE BILL
PRESERVES THAT I'LL BE VOTING
AYE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I DO HAVE A COMMENT BECAUSE THIS
IS VERY CRITICAL PART OF THIS
BILL FOR ME AS WELL ARMENIA.
GIVING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NOTIFICATION IS VERY VERY
CRITICAL TO ME.
.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS WE JUST REALLY THAT
THAT'S A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ASPECT TO ME.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT THIS
AMENDMENT. IS.
IF JUDGE ORDERS NO AMENDMENT
HERE.
.
THE LEFT TO GO IN YOUR WORD.
IT WILL RESOLVE THAT IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY AND. IT NEEDS TO
BE.
VERY.
TIMELY NOTIFICATION.
AS THAT IS WHAT I WOULD ASK FOR.
OKAY.
I JUST READ IT DOES.
CLOSE RESPECT LAST FREE AYE
VOTE.
ON AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE.
SANTIAGO.
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
NOW HAVE TWIN AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO.
COMMUNITY SERVICE CONVERSION.
.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TO WOULD
SURE THAT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PAINT INFRACTION FIND THE VALUE
OF ONE HOUR OF COMMUNITY SERVICE
IS AT LEAST DOUBLED.
THE CALIFORNIA MINIMUM WAGE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES
CALIFORNIA FEES AND FINES ARE
AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION.
AS AN EXAMPLE THE BASELINE FOR
RED LIGHT VIOLATIONS A HUNDRED
DOLLARS BUT AFTER PENALTIES AND
ASSESSMENT THE TOTAL AMOUNT DUE
IS FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
DOLLARS.
THESE LARGE FINE AMOUNTS OR
BURDENSOME FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
COURTS DO HAVE THE DISCRETION TO
SENTENCE INDIVIDUAL TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE IF THE TOTAL FINE AMOUNT
WOULD CAUSE A FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP.
THE CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE A
CONSISTENT MINIMUM RATE FOR
CONVERTING COMMUNITY SERVICE
HOURS. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO
WOULD REVENUE THIS BY PROVIDING
A UNIFORM RATE FOR CONVERTING
INFRACTION FINDS INTO COMMUNITY
SERVICE HOURS SPECIFICALLY TO
CONVERSION RATE WOULD BE EQUAL
TO NO LESS THAN DOUBLE THE
MINIMUM WAGE. WAGE RATE FOR
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WOULD A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE DISH
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. IN HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL MEMBERS OUR RESPECT LAST
FREE AYE VOTE. MOVED TO BELL.
AND THE LIVING BOMB JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VERY MUCH FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL WE'RE PLEASED
TO SPONSOR IT AS HE SAID OUR
FEES AND FINES ARE HIGH IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS ALREADY ARE
OFFERING. COMMUNITY SERVICE TO
PEOPLE FOR WHOM IT IS.
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAVE THE DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FINES AND
FEES AND THIS JUST CREATES A
REASONABLE RATE AT WHICH THEIR
COMMUNITY SERVICE HOURS SHALL BE
VALUED.
YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMENTS.
SO WHY DO WE CHOOSE TWENTY TWO
AYE TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE IS
THE APPROPRIATE.
YOU KNOW AMOUNT OF
REIMBURSEMENT.
SO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL EXPLORED
THAT VERY ISSUE AND IT WE LOOKED
AT A NUMBER OF ALTERNATIVES WE
THOUGHT OF CREATING A STANDARD
RATE JUST A DOLLAR AMOUNT AND WE
DECIDED THAT'S NOT REASONABLE
BECAUSE ECONOMIES CHANGE AND SO
CREATING A DOLLAR AMOUNT
STATUTES SEEMED A LITTLE BIT.
INFLEXIBLE WE THOUGHT ABOUT JUST
THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT WE FELT
THAT WHEN SOMEBODY IS GIVING UP
A PERHAPS A DAY OF WORK.
PERHAPS THEY'RE MAKING MORE
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE TO ONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VALUE FOR
THEIR TIME GIVING TO SOCIETY IS
REASONABLE WE DIDN'T WANT THEM
TO BE. PAYING LESS THAN SOMEBODY
WOULD BE PAYING IN FINES SO WE
TRIED TO CREATE A MIDDLE GROUND
THAT EQUATED THE VALUE OF THEIR
TIME TO THE AMOUNT THAT THEY
WOULD BE PAYING IN DOLLARS.
OKAY NO FURTHER QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION.
THERE'S LIKE CLOSE.
SPECTRUM THREE AYE VOTE.
AB TWENTY BY THIRTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE CHANCER AYE LACKEY
AYE AYE LACKEY I GOT RIO.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
HIGHLY NOT VOTING QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU.
OF.
AB TWO SIX SIX NINE OF PEACE
OFFICERS COMMUNICATIONS A. B..
TO SUCCESS NINE WILL AT THE
PEACE OFFICERS OF CORRECTIONAL
SAFETY
SPECIAL SERVICES UNION AS A FEW
AND EIGHT OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS . I A WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION CDC ARE TOO
PENAL CODE SIX THREE THREE.
MUCH OF THE EVIDENCE GATHERED BY
THE SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT AND
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
IS OBTAINED WHILE UNDERCOVER OR
HAPPENSTANCE. BUT WHEN SUBMITTED
TO LOCAL DISTRIBUTARY. ISN'T
AFTER IS THE AFTER IS AFTER THE
FACT AND NOT PERMISSIBLE AS
LEGAL EVIDENCE BECAUSE NEITHER
OF THE SWORN PEACE OFFICERS ARE
INCLUDED IN PENAL CODES.
SIX THREE THREE MANY TIMES
EVIDENCE IS PRESENTED IS
OFFICERS WHILE PERFORMING THEIR
DUTIES ARE JUST HAPPEN TO BE
REVEALED ACCIDENTALLY WITHOUT
PRE PLANNING.
SPECIAL SERVICES UNIT AND THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS ARE
RESTRICTED FROM USING THIS
EVIDENCE BECAUSE THEY NEED A
LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
WARRANT PRIOR TO GAMING BE
EVIDENCE. THIS PROBLEM IS WHY
PEACE OFFICER AGENCIES ARE
LISTED IN PENAL CODE SIX THREE
THREE INCH AND WHY SF YOU AND
I A OF CDC ARE NEED TO BE
ADDED.
OUT WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
MICHAEL BRODY A FIELD OFFICER
WITH SS YOU AND FORD CANOE.
A OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATIONS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IBM.
OF GOOD AFTERNOON OF MY NAME'S
FORD CANET I'M A MINISTRY TO THE
SYSTEM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION.
FOR MANY YEARS.
SS YOU AND  I A WHICH OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND SPECIAL
SERVICE UNIT.
WORKED UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
SIX THIRTY THREE BECAUSE THEY
WORK WITH.
OTHER POLICE AGENCIES TO BUILD
THEIR CRIMINAL CASES.
BUT AFTER.
AB ONE OH NINE AND.
PROP FORTY SEVEN.
.
THE POLICE HAD THE SHERIFF'S.
HAD A LOT MORE PUT ON THEIR
PLATE.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE MANPOWER TO ASSIST AS A FEW
ORAL A IN BUILDING THEIR CASES.
QUITE OFTEN EVERYDAY SOMETIMES
WE STILL DO AND SO THERE'S STILL
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF SIX SIX
THREE WITH THE PENAL CODE.
BUT.
SINCE THAT TIME.
ESSAYS YOU WHICH IS AN
UNDERCOVER ORGANIZATION WHO
WEARS WIRES. WHO OF WIRETAPS
UNDER BODY AND ALSO?
HAVE.
CONFIDENTIAL A NETWORK OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS
BECAUSE THEY INNER DIPPED
BETWEEN PRISON GANGS IN THE
STREET GANGS.
AND THEY ALSO.
UP PURSUE ESCAPEES.
.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY BUILD THEIR
CASES FROM THE TOP DOWN ALL BY
THEMSELVES WITHOUT.
THE OTHER PEACE OFFICERS THEY
NOW DON'T HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
BEING UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF SIX
SIX THREE THAT. THE IT BETTER
THEY NEED TO BE LISTED IN IT.
SO THEY DON'T LOSE THE EVIDENCE
THAT THEY GARNER.
WELL OUT IN THE FIELD.
AND.
.
AS FAR AWAY WE OWE A IS TRYING
TO PLEASE FIFTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
AND THERE'S BAD APPLES OUT THERE
AND ANY ORGANIZATION OF FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND THERE'S A
LOT OF CRIMINAL ACTS A BRINGING
IN.
DRUGS INTO THE INSTITUTION
WE'VE HAD GANG MEMBERS BECOME
PEACE OFFICERS BECAUSE THEY
PASSED BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS
WITHOUT A MYRIAD OF CRIMES.
THAT OF ALL A HAVE TO
INVESTIGATE AND IF THEY'RE NOT.
IF THEY'RE NOT.
.
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL POLICE
THEN THEY'RE NOT UNDER THE SIX
SIX THREE ON UMBRELLA AND THEY
ALSO NEED TO BE LISTED.
TODAY I BROUGHT.
AGENT OF MICHAEL BRODY.
INDEED HE'S.
HAS A TWENTY FIVE YEAR CAREER
IN NEVIS UNDERCOVER AGENT FOR SS
YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR LET ME SHARE A
LITTLE BIT. I'M A LOT OF PEOPLE
REALIZE THAT S. ISSUE IS
ACTUALLY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARMOR CITY ARE THAT WE ALL WORK
INSIDE PRISON WE ACTUALLY WORKED
STREET.
NOW SWITCHED BACK INTO MY
POCKET.
AND UP. WE'RE WE'RE THE ONLY
PART OF CDC ARE THAT IT'S UNDER
A THIRTY POINT TWO FOUR AS A
PEACE OFFICER WITH FULL TIME
PEACE OFFICER STATUS. IN A
MILLION THINGS THAT WE DO WE WE
INVESTIGATE COMPLICATED CRIMINAL
GANGS.
CASES IN USUALLY S. AND A SEEN
BY MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AS THE
GANG EXPERTS SO WHEN THEY HAVE A
CASE THAT'S.
HAS A CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION
NEXUS THAT FLOWS OF COMES INTO
THE PRISON OR THE PRESENCE.
D. S. STAFFED IN INFORMATION AS
IT RELATES TO CRIMINAL GANGS ON
THE STREETS WE WERE CALLED IN TO
INVESTIGATE THAT AND WORK WITH
LOCAL PEOPLE LOCAL AGENCIES. IN
BUILDING THOSE CASES FOR THEM
AND LIKE MISTER CANNOT SAID WE
MANY TIMES WHERE THE LEAD CO
AGED AND SO WE'RE DOING THE
DIRECT FILING.
WE ALSO DO X. SCAPES NAM WHEN
GUYS X. GAPE WALK AWAY FROM FIRE
CAMPS OR PRISONS WE'RE THE ONES
IN PURSUIT OF THOSE.
AND WHAT.
BE COVERED ON SIX THIRTY THREE
WHAT IT DOES FOR US IS IT ALLOWS
US IN THE COURSE OF OUR
INVESTIGATION WHETHER WE WORK
UNDERCOVER. WORKING WITH
INFORMANTS OR IN THE MIDDLE OF
OUR INVESTIGATION IT ALLOWS US
TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE. A
SPONTANEOUS STATEMENTS MADE.
REGARDING THEM THE CRIMINAL ACTS
THAT WERE INVESTIGATING OR OTHER
CRIMINAL ACTS THAT WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THAT SOMEBODY.
CONFESSES WITHOUT BEING THAT
COVERED UNDER THAT SIX THIRTY
THREE WE CANNOT USE THAT AND
COR.
EVEN THOUGH.
IT. WE HAVE THE INFORMATION.
SO THE GO BACK AND GET A WARRANT
AFTER THAT TO CALL BACK AND TRY
TO RE INTERVIEW AND CAN SAY THE
SAME STATEMENTS PUTS US AT A
HANDICAP.
THAT OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE TO WORK
UNDER THAT WE DO JUST BECAUSE WE
WERE LEFT OUT OF THIS.
THE SPIN CHO.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS.
OF CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. OF CALIFORNIA
NARCOTICS OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
LA COUNTY PROFESSIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
IT WERE ALL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY.
TAKES CARE OF A STATUTORY GAP
THAT WAS INADVERTENTLY MAY THANK
YOU.
QUALQUER ON BEHALF THE
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ORGANIZATION.
TOO STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS IS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
INSTANTLY MATHIS SOMEHOW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
QUITE SIMPLY WE THINK THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS PROVIDED
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW AND THE
LIMITED EXCEPTIONS FOR SOME BUT
NOT ALL TYPES OF PEACE OFFICERS.
HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR FIFTY
YEARS.
AND DON'T SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN
A CASE MADE FORTUNES REVISITING
THAT DECISION.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME ON WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THAT ABI DESERTING
IT AS TO THE SPECIFIC WORK FOR
PEACE OFFICER.
PEACE OFFICERS REQUESTING.
.
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE EXCEPTION
IS IS GOING TO LEAD TO. A ONE
AND ANOTHER AND AND.
RE OPENING THE WHOLE QUESTION OF
WHICH PEACE OFFICERS ARE
ACCEPTED FOR IT FROM THE
EXISTING LAW WE ASK FOR YOUR
NOVEL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ARE YOU OPPOSED TO SIX SIX
THREE GENERALLY.
ARE THE ABILITY OF POLICE
OFFICERS TO REPORT.
AS.
TO THE COURT.
I MEAN IS IT IS SISSACH CONCERN
I MEAN I THINK THEY MADE A GREAT
CASE THAT THEY'RE LIKE OTHER
POLICE OFFICERS WHY SHOULDN'T WE
INCLUDE THEM.
ARE YOU GENERALLY AGAINST SIX
SIX THREE WHICH ALLOWS THIS FOR
OTHER POLICE OFFICERS ARE YOU
SPIT DO YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC
REASON. FOR EXCLUDING THIS
GROUP.
NO I WOULDN'T SAY WE ARE
GENERALLY OPPOSED I I THINK THAT
THAT BALANCE THAT WAS STRUCK.
DAVID IT.
IT EXTENDED THE THE EXCEPTION
TO.
MOST KINDS OF.
PEACE OFFICERS AND AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BUT BUT
THERE ARE MANY KINDS WHO ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE EXCEPTION.
.
YOU KNOW TO OUR KNOWLEDGE IT IT
HAS NOT PRESENTED A PROBLEM FOR
THOSE AGENCIES AND DOING THEIR
WORK.
AND AND WE'RE HESITANT TO SEE.
THE EXPANSION OF THE EXCEPTION
SO THAT THAT THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS ARE ARE NARROWED.
IN TERMS OF OF WHERE THEY APPLY
GOT IT SO I'LL BE VOTING AYE ON
THE BILL I JUST DON'T SEE A
GREAT DEAL OF DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT LOCAL POLICE TO. IN THEIR
TASK FORCES AND WHAT THIS GROUP
IS DOING SO HOT IF I SAW A
DIFFERENCE OF SOME TYPE.
AND YOU COULD TELL ME WHAT THAT
IS I. MIGHT CONSIDER VOTING NO
BUT RIGHT NOW I'M VOTING AYE.
LETS YOU CAN THINK OF A GOOD
REASON THAT THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SAY LOCAL POLICE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WELL MOTION.
YES AND ONE SECOND WE'RE READY
FOR THE QUESTION.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER.
JUMPS ARE AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
QUIRK QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY VOTE AT ARMS WHO
CHANGES.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE WAS PUT BY
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ%
FLETCHER NO ON RECONSIDERATION
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
I.
FOR NINETEEN.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE. KILEY.
ALONG RECONSIDERATION FOR
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE I.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GOV FELLAS FLETCHER I HIGHLY.
HIGHLY AYE SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
NUMBER FIVE WAS PULLED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY THIRTEEN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE SAN DIEGO.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. ITEM.
SEATING ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO TWENTY TWO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY SIX JONES SAWYER.
JOHN SAWYER AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SIX BY MISTER KILEY.
.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR TWELVE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
AT A NUMBER FOURTEEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN BY
MISTER PATTERSON.
I OTHER RECONSIDERATION FOR
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
IT AND NUMBER SIXTEEN WITH FUND
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTEEN PATIO. GALILEO AYE
SANTIAGO.
AT UNDER EIGHTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SANTIAGO.
ITEM TWENTY WAS I CONFESS.
ITEM TWENTY ONE DAY BETWEEN SIX
SIXTY NINE SANTIAGO.
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NO ONE RUBIO GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM TWENTY THREE WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THREE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THEMSELVES
BETTER NOW ON RECONSIDERATION.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO WITHIN SIX
WITHOUT CONSENT AN ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN WAS SUNK.
THE COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED